Boom,
and we're live.
There's a lot of rich people in the
world,
but it's not a lot of rich people live
in like you.
So first of all,
before we even get started,
I salute you sir,
because if I was a 16 year old kid and I
won the lottery,
I'd be living exactly the way you live.
Like if you asked a 16 year old kid,
hey man,
if you had 100 million bucks,
what would you do?
Oh Dude,
I just have,
I just have bitches around me all the
time.
I'd be jet skiing,
I'd be driving around in Ferrari's and
private jets.
You live in like a,
a life that doesn't even seem real.
It's A.
Does it seem real to you?
Um,
now it seems normal.
As crazy as that sounds.
I've been doing it for awhile,
but that's actually kind of exactly what
I did.
I was um,
I think it started in maybe like 2000,
11,
12.
So I had a girlfriend for about two or
three years and she was pretty happy
that she was a playmate.
She had like 100,000
followers and she was going to move to
La to become famous and this and that.
And we ended up breaking up and I
actually ended up getting a place in San
Diego.
Then I got a place in La and I started
playing this real big poker and I mean I
beat one guy for like $54 million and
then I'd be another guy for like 10 and
you know,
so there's some pretty big Christ.
Yeah,
like,
you know what I'm saying,
it's just like there are some pretty big
wins there.
And uh,
and I was single and I was just like,
you know what,
fuck it.
I'm just Kinda Kinda like do bucket list
shit.
Like whatever,
like whatever I wanted to do when I was
a kid,
I'm just going to fucking deal,
you know.
And I just did and I posted about it and
it was like,
part of the posting was because I knew
it'd be able to get me some pussy
without like actually speaking to girls,
which was good.
And then there's like another piece of
it where it was kind of like a fuck you
to her,
but it was never like really to become
famous,
you know what I mean?
It was just kinda like just doing my
thing and you know,
we're getting pictures here and there.
Uh,
and then it kind of,
I mean fuck it's,
you know,
I mean I sent you some of the stats.
I mean I think like a week ago,
like I fuck,
I reach a $175 million people.
Just those insane you sent me,
uh,
some,
some measurement of all the different
people that are looking at your stuff.
And I'll read it because it's insane.
Analytics.
Yeah.
Like it doesn't even make sense.
These,
it's hundreds of millions of people here
will see hidden hundred 61 million,
300,
4,000,
941 impressions this week.
That's insane.
Grant,
you know,
like facebook's a whole nother thing.
And,
and,
and it's really underrepresented because
first of all everybody else is buying
all their followers and the likes and
all their shifts.
So there's this like really inflated and
also I actually kind of like the
opposite because I got a lot of people
that are looking at my shit.
They can't really be seen looking at my
shit,
you know what I mean?
Like there was like some big producer,
I won't say his name,
but like every time I posted a girl,
like they get hit up in the D and this
is like a big,
big,
like,
you know,
like fucking,
like $100,
million
dollar movies and shit.
And he's like,
hits them all up,
you know.
So there's like a lie.
It just stopped me out like this
Marsianno this fucking guy is like every
time I posted chick she's got a guest
campaign now,
you know.
So it's like,
it's kind of funny,
you know,
it's great for them to.
Then what,
what I'm saying is they're not actually
like officially fall and click that
button on my shit.
They're stocking you.
Target.
Yeah.
So they hit that search button and
you're at the top of the list always
because they're always searching you.
That's funny.
Seems like.
So how long has this been going on?
When did you start making all these
crazy posts?
And when did this gambling rampage
start?
Um,
well,
I mean I've been here
gamble for a long time,
but um,
I think kind of the craziness I would
say started in 2012 probably.
I just distinctly remember because I,
I won like $11,
million bucks in a night and my buddy
who I just give them like $2,000
to made me a million off it because he
got second in the world series of poker.
So I had like a $12,000,000
a week.
So I was like,
fuck it,
I'm going to take this dude down to
Puerto Vallarta with a bunch of chicks
and we're going to have fun,
you know.
And that was Kinda like,
um,
that was,
that was one of the big.
Actually not,
I'm sorry,
I take that back.
I'd broken up with my girlfriend and it
was a buddy of mine,
nick cassavetes,
who he's like know he's pretty big.
Uh,
he did like the notebook and blow and
you know,
like the director or whatever.
And um,
I played poker with him a lot and I just
broke it up my girl and I was like,
Hey,
let's go down to Cabo,
I'm going to bring some chicks.
And it was supposed to be me,
him and one other guy and the other guy
ended up bailing but he had committed so
he paid for his part of the trip.
So it was me and nick and I think it was
like,
I want to say 17 chicks.
I remember I had sex nine times in one
day.
I was like,
so proud of myself,
right.
I think by the end I was like,
it was like dust was coming out.
It was like,
it was funny because I didn't even want
to have sex the night time,
but it was just kinda like a,
like a matter of principle.
It's like have a billion a billionaires
walking down the street and he sees $100
bill.
He says,
always going to pick it up.
You know what I mean?
That was me.
I didn't get a lot of pussy when I was
younger.
So it was like,
it was a hot chick,
fuck.
We like,
I didn't care about wanting to beggars,
just like obligation.
So 17 girls.
Yep.
Now the pay these girls to come.
Okay.
So that's the big misconception on
addressing that.
On my app.
I actually nap,
I've got an APP coming out and I'm just
going to basically,
but you know what,
I'll give it to you for free,
you know?
So um,
I'm not opposed to paying for sex,
you know,
like,
I mean I have in the past like I've,
you know,
fuck thousands of girls.
So it's like,
you know,
and I paid for maybe like 10 or 20,
something like that.
And it's not because I have any moral
dilemma about it and it's not because I
think it's wrong.
Um,
in fact,
I think like sex for money is one of the
most like pure interactions because the
guy gets what he wants,
the girl gets what she wants.
There's no bullshit.
I think like this whole like sugar
daddy,
sugar baby thing is the biggest fucked
up part because then the guy's like
pretending to like the girl pretending
he's not
fucking other girls.
The girls pretending to like him.
It's just like all this like convoluted
bullshit is prostitution at the end of
the day,
like it is paying for sex.
Right.
But they're not coming out and saying
it.
It's not like,
hey,
I want x and I'll give you why.
It's like the guy from the clippers,
donald sterling and that girl.
Come on man,
these are all,
they all have like,
you know,
these five girlfriends there supporting
them and then the girls have other
boyfriends.
They don't tell,
you know,
and it's this whole fucked up thing.
But like I said,
but for me,
like I said,
it's not a moral thing.
It's not a.
I mean for me it's not a monetary thing.
Obviously I'd much prefer to just give a
girl money fucker and be done.
But for me,
if the girl's not into me then I'm just
like kind of not into the sex.
So that's the hangup for me.
But no,
I,
that's actually healthy.
Yeah,
I mean it is.
I mean make these big judgments there.
They're going to make big judgments on
you first of all because you're doing
some stuff that's just like so far to
the right end of the spectrum.
It doesn't even make sense.
Like how the fuck is he pulling all this
off?
It doesn't.
It's like it seems unattainable,
so they're gonna make well he's this guy
is wrong and these gi would never do
that.
They're saying a bunch of crazy shit
because the way you're living is just so
bizarre.
But at the end of the day,
that's the thing,
like people just can't wrap their hands
around the fact that like,
you know,
they,
because so many guys are paying right
now,
like people are tricking off in record
numbers because of instagram and all
this stuff and the access that people
have like
tricking off being,
paying for,
paying for sex in like record numbers.
Like it's unbelief.
First of all,
it should be legal,
just like getting a massage should be
legal.
No,
nobody wants to rub your feet.
Nobody wants to suck your Dick,
but it should be able to pay both of
them.
It's the oldest profession like since
the history of time.
It is.
Well,
not only that,
they taught chimpanzees the value of
currency that gave chimpanzees coins and
they gave them coins and then every time
the chimps had given the coins to back
to the people that give them candy.
You know the chimps did the first
fucking thing they did.
They gave the coins,
the female chimps,
and they fucked up surveys.
That's the first thing they did,
and the researchers like Jesus.
That is number one.
The first thing they did,
that's what it added.
Another layer.
I used to have a little bit about it.
It's nothing.
There's nothing wrong with it and like
making pleasure.
A crime is ridiculous.
There's no victim,
no one's getting her.
Think of all the shitty jobs that you
can get paid to do.
You can get paid to clean toilets.
You can get paid to fucking insulate
addicts.
There's a lot of terrible jobs that you
can get paid to mop up the.
Come on a fucking on the floors of these
like,
you know,
jerk houses or the place or whatever,
it's,
it's like,
I don't know.
I,
like I said,
I have no issues with it.
I think it should be legal.
Um,
it's a victimless crime.
Yeah.
I just
like for,
like I said,
for me it's,
it's the,
it's the mental thing and I just like,
I,
I got,
I couldn't fuck all the girls,
you know,
if I had five dicks.
So it's like,
what?
And I'm not like bragging like
I used to,
I'm just,
you know,
I'm just kicking you the real deal,
you know?
It's like I should.
I said,
there's no victims.
I kissed.
There is some,
there's victims of some prostitution,
right?
There's a people that are abducted and
there's certain people that are like sex
traffic,
like sex slaves.
That's real,
but we're not talking about it
that we're talking about.
That's exactly what you said,
that,
that sex slavery,
that's not really like a girl saying,
hey,
I want x for y.
that's her saying,
hey,
you got to do this and you're getting
your ass beat.
There's a big way,
bigger difference,
a big difference between that and a lot
of what you see in La as these girls,
they want to wear the nice purses and
have nice shoes and they don't really
want a job and they want to live in a
nice apartment but they don't want to
work.
How do I work this out?
And by the way,
getting back to your last thing,
if it was legal,
there wouldn't be,
you know,
the pimp saying,
hey,
you're going to do this.
You're gonna.
Get your ass beat.
It will all be regulated just like drug
dealers and also then than the
beginning,
you know,
tested and you know,
they're just be like a whole regulated
system.
Exactly.
I mean,
as much as I hate pain pills and as much
as I have lost friends to pain pills and
oxides and all this different shit,
there's no fucking wars being fought
over it.
There's not blood in the streets of war
as Mexico over pain pills.
You know,
all that shit is over drugs that are
illegal.
As soon as those drugs become legal,
I think probably less people would use
them and you'd get tax dollars from them
and the least there would be some sort
of a solution in terms of treatment and
responsibility and he'd be able to look
at it a little bit differently.
Yeah.
I just think there's too much money and
kickbacks for that to happen,
but I,
I totally agree.
I mean,
I think alcohol is far worse for you
than many drugs and I mean,
you know,
I mean how many times have you seen
people get into fights or shoot people
or you know,
wreck their cars because they're high on
al or high on weed,
you know,
it never happens.
Never happens on alcohol,
you know,
more people are dying from alcohol
related deaths and there are firearms,
but they want to ban the guns,
you know?
Yeah.
It's,
there's,
there's a lot of real problems with that
for sure.
And you know,
there's also these companies like the
company that makes a fentanyl fentanyl,
it's super strong pain pill,
a painkiller that's 10 times at least
more powerful than a oxycontin's.
I believe that's what the numbers,
they're spending $500,000
just to keep marijuana illegal in
Arizona because they're,
you know,
they've got it on the ballot to make it
recreationally legal in the state of
Arizona and so they're putting out all
these ads and they have this whole
campaign to try to sway people,
but they're just doing it for business.
It has nothing to do with public safety
or health.
You see a fucking thing about Hillary
Clinton.
One of the Wiki leaks things that
Hillary Clinton,
she.
Wikileaks released some paper where she
was in communication with bankers,
one of the emails and she was saying
that she was going to stop weed and that
she was going to make sure that we're,
uh,
was not legal.
Then she was gonna,
do her best and stand her ground.
And all this nonsense leak reveals
Clinton promise bankers to stand against
marijuana legalization.
Like,
what the fuck?
Hillary.
She's pretty brutal.
Just what the fuck.
I know you're bought and sold,
but don't you have enough money,
lady,
how much money you need?
Unless you're gambling with Dan
Bilzerian,
where the fuck's all your money going?
I read.
It's kind of funny because what did they
pay these presidents like 250 k a year,
$400,000
a year and they're all worth hundreds of
millions of dollar or billionaires,
you know,
it's insane.
Yeah.
Well,
not only that,
like she was trying to say that once
bill got out of the office,
he was dead broke.
Well,
you're not dead broke now,
so how the fuck did you guys make all
that money that they're worth hundreds
and hundreds of millions of dollars.
It's all from speaking arrangements and
pay to play and weird fucking shady
deals they have with banks and they do
these speeches that nobody wants to
fucking here and they pay him a quarter
million bucks an hour.
So preposterous.
Yeah.
I mean,
the more money you have and the more you
kind of rub shoulders with these people,
you kind of get a look behind the
curtain and you see that,
you know,
it's just uh,
it's,
I mean politics.
If you look up the definition of
politics,
I mean it's like bullshitting,
right?
Well that is being political is not
being yourself,
which is the opposite of what you're
doing.
I mean you're kind of like an anti
politician it a lot of ways,
but do you want to get at though is do
you get hit up because you're,
you're so wealthy.
Do you get hit up by people that are in
the political spectrum that want to use
your influence and your.
You have,
how many followers do you have?
A 19 point something on instagram and
it's 10 and a half million on facebook
and twitter.
Twitter,
but I mean that's insane.
The whole UFC.
Yeah.
The reach is tracking
point 2 million followers.
That's crazy.
And it's all just pictures of you
grabbing titties.
Like,
look at this one right here.
This is what?
This one's hilarious.
It's like someone told you that you
shouldn't.
You should post something a little more
team is like,
you got to clean this up.
You know,
like,
you know there's a new team.
Fuck your team.
Like there's all this money out there.
You know,
you know this,
this,
uh,
this rocky got paid $70,
million bucks to indoors for the,
like you can make all this money.
Yeah.
Oh,
what do you do with it?
Just drive a truck.
A big truck.
It does afford a commercial $70 million.
It's probably worth it though for them.
The Rock has like $67 million or some
insane shit,
but he's a goddamn movie star.
Do two takes pictures with.
That's a thing,
you know,
like I feel like I got to be maybe the
most famous guy that never had like a TV
show or like a real talent.
One hundred percent.
No one even close.
That's kind of rare to be like number
one and anything,
you know.
So that's kind of cool.
You're the number one baller.
Well I don't know about that from
America.
We're the number one power.
I'm giving you the crown right now.
Burger King,
crown.
I put it on your head.
I can tell you some stories about some
guys that know who you are when nobody
knows who they are.
Public ball for sure.
I'm the only guy that's kind of putting
it out there because,
you know,
most guys they got,
they got a job,
they get a wife,
the family,
you know,
whatever.
I just Kinda just said fuck all of it,
you know,
like they can accept
me or not and I,
I'm just going to do it all.
How old are you?
Thirty five.
Do you think that there's gonna come a
day when this is going to be tired and
if you,
if it does come a day,
do you think you're ever going to go the
marriage route?
Is that possible at this point?
So look,
you know,
I'm a gambler.
I don't want to bet half of my net
worth.
I'm a lucky girl forever,
but that's not to say that I wouldn't
have a girlfriend or you know what I'm
capable of being monogamous.
Um,
you know,
it's just for me it's more about options
really.
Look at the end of the day,
it comes down to most guys earn
relationships I feel like because it's
either,
hey,
I'm going to jerk off on Saturday night
or I've got to put up with her shit.
And I get laid,
you know,
and it's like in a lot of,
it's out of laziness.
A lot of it's not a lack of options,
whatever the case may be,
but it's not correct.
Like for me,
I think a correct relationship as a guy
that could be fucking,
you know,
five or 10 girls and he chooses to hang
out with this one girl because he likes
her and he likes hanging out with her
and she hangs out with him because she
enjoys his company.
And regardless of what the reason is,
you know,
because a lot of people are like,
Oh,
you know,
that girl's a gold digger or they want
to hate on them.
Um,
but you know,
at the end of the day if a guy has made
his money from successful business and,
you know,
being smart and,
and he hasn't fucked it off like,
you know,
or he's a doctor,
whatever.
That to me is more of a part of who that
guy is.
Then a girl that's just born hot.
So for a guy to like a girl just because
she's hot,
I feel like it's like the most
superficial thing of all time.
Well,
I mean chess would be nice to.
She can't.
I mean hopefully she does,
but I'm saying a lot of guys are with a
girl just because she's hot and they
don't really get as much shit as a girl
that's with a guy because he's
successful because he has money.
It's true.
It is true.
Like the guy who earned that money,
it's his character and his willpower and
his discipline that's allowed him,
his smarts is allowed him to earn that
money or he just got lucky as fuck.
And there's definitely some lucky ones
but
you know,
you also have to hold onto it.
I mean once you got money,
I mean you got every asshole and their
mother with their handout,
you know,
trying to scam you and it's easy to,
fuck it off or
you know,
make bad investments or you know,
whatever the case might be.
Yeah,
it is.
That's,
it is a funny little situation there,
isn't it?
Because like it's also the way women are
allowed to dress even like a,
like a respectable woman is allowed to
have her tits pressed together and
pushed up and she's allowed to have a
skirt that's just like a little,
a little light,
vagina curtain,
you know,
and it's really all it is.
Little panties underneath and smooth
legs and high heels.
I mean the whole thing is sex selling,
lust.
Let's talk about bathing suits and the
fact that every bathing suit now,
is it basically a thong and the fact
that like a bathing suit shows more than
like the most revealing underwear back
in the day.
Ever used to,
but it's like completely socially
acceptable.
Then on Halloween they could wear even
less than that.
They paint.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's like literally,
but naked.
When the fuck did paint become close,
magically put on our deck and went
out.
You'd get arrested,
right?
Well how come a girl can wear on tits
became,
were paying on your Dick?
I want to know.
Oh,
that's a double standard.
It is a double standard.
Nobody wants to see your Dick painted it
up.
That's why especially with like American
flag or something.
Yeah.
I don't want to see a bunch of zebra.
It is weird.
There are weird double standards,
but it's also people don't want to open
their mouth because they don't want.
First of all,
they don't want anybody to think that
they,
you know,
like why do women get do is not,
oh,
what are you complaining?
Poor guy,
you know,
you don't want to hear that.
But it's also when men complain about
the double standard in like,
like marriage,
like what you said as far as it being a
gamble.
It's a terrible gamble for a wealthy
man.
It's terrible because it's,
it's essentially a financial agreement.
It's not a love agreement.
Well No,
you're asking the government permission
to be with a girl and if you decide that
you don't want to be with them,
now you have to go ask the government
and then you have to get lawyers
involved.
And it's this whole process that in my
eyes it makes both parties field.
Well,
not both parties because usually,
you know,
it's kind of like a magnet,
like one is pushing a little bit further
than,
than the other.
And so there's one kind of like always
chasing or whatever.
So for me it just makes the party that's
a little bit less invested,
just feel trapped.
And when you're in a relationship and
you feel trapped,
the first thing you want to do is run,
right?
So you've got this one person,
you know,
that inevitably ends up feeling trapped
and the other person you know,
kind of gets lazy or complacent.
And I feel like it just snowballs,
you know,
there's like a lot of momentum things,
right?
So if relationships just starts kind of
going downhill and you're trapped in it
because you're legally bound,
I just feel like it's just gonna get
worse and worse and the girl is going to
stop giving them blowjobs and the guy's
going to resent it and then maybe he
cheats.
You know what I mean?
It's like this whole cycle that just
wouldn't happen if you were hanging out
because he wanted to hang out because
let's face it,
if you're,
if you're hanging out with the chicken,
you like her,
she's cool and then she just decides to
just completely let herself go and she
turns into a fat ass and or she just
like stopped wanting to have sex and
you're just going to fuck other girls or
you're just not going to hang out with
it.
Right.
But if you're married to or you don't
really have a choice.
I mean now you're kind of like,
you got to ask the government permission
and you know,
this and that.
Yeah.
You got to get lawyers involved.
You live in the same place.
You gotta Oh,
it takes forever.
You have to agree on terms and you have
to pay for her lawyer.
Do you mean how brutal is that?
Like you're like literally like trapped
in the same house as the birth,
you know,
it's just like,
it can get crazy,
it can get crazy and I've seen it get
crazy.
I'm sure you have to.
When people get divorced,
I mean it is one of the most stressful
things a person go through in their life
and when you're working,
you're working all day and if she's not
working,
that's when it's really crazy.
I had a buddy who was going through a
divorce,
his wife never worked and he was working
10,
12 hours a day,
just busting his ass constantly as his
own business and she would be fucking
off and doing whatever she wanted during
the day.
He had to pay for all that on top of
paying for her lawyer and her lawyer was
trying to fuck him and then he had to
pay for his lawyer to paddle her and
they all
just dragged the whole thing out.
Took over a year and a half for him to
get divorced.
Suffix,
a year and a half.
This poor bastard just means free now,
but God damn,
but try to get them married now.
He'll fucking shoot you in the face if
you even bring up that word.
It's like he went through it.
I mean they have a term for it and
gambling.
It's a negative free role.
It's where you can basically only lose,
you have no upside.
You know,
like for instance,
a negative free roll is like if I were
to tell you,
hey,
um,
you know,
if you can go bench press 300 pounds,
I'll give you $10,000.
Well I just can't win anything,
you know what I mean?
Because if you can't do it then I don't
get anything.
So it's Kinda like in my eyes,
I just feel like as a situation where
you can just lose its kinda like my
buddy he got into a relationship and he
just dove in like super hardcore really
fast and I just told them,
I said look like I just feel like you
don't have a lot of upside by doing that
because you know,
you can get hurt and if you just take it
slow,
like worst case scenario,
you know,
you just weren't quite as close for a
month.
But I said,
you know,
if it doesn't work out then now you
invested all this time and this effort
and it's like.
And I feel like because he went so
hardcore for this girl,
it Kinda like,
you know,
sometimes it makes them run away a
little bit because they know people,
you know,
they just by nature want what,
they can't have rights.
If you just give it all to him
immediately,
then it's Kinda like,
like look at this bitch.
Yeah,
exactly.
The kind of like lose respect for you a
little bit.
It can happen or it can be perfect.
You know,
relationships just have to be organic.
That's what it really has to be.
And as soon as you involve legal
contracts,
it's not organic anymore.
Exactly.
Once it,
once I feel like once it starts to be
forced in anyway,
you know,
then well it's when there's no
prenuptial to.
That's when things get really screwy.
You know,
when you find out how much people
actually have to pay.
Like I've talked about it on my podcast
before,
but I have another buddy who's paying
his ex wife for the rest of her life.
They were married for 12 years.
He has to pay her forever.
Forever.
Yeah.
She's got a new boyfriend.
He's married,
he's got kids now with another woman to
the most brutal part.
It's when they,
when they get to the boyfriend and now
you're like support and this dude to
bang your wife.
Not only that,
the dude lives in his house and every
time they send a lawyer over to check
the date,
the guy packs up his stuff.
It's like a joke.
He throws it in a u haul.
He drives around the corner,
waits for the inspector to leave,
goes all the way around and brings the
shit back.
It's fucking insanity because you know,
he's got this baller house in the
palisades is living with this girl and
the only way she gets screwed up because
if she marries this guy,
but this guy doesn't have any money,
so she's never going to marry this guy.
I mean she would,
she would have to bank on marrying this
guy would be worth,
I think my buddy pays or somewhere
around a half million dollars a year
forever.
Forever for life.
So they've been,
were married for 12 years,
had been divorced for 15.
So He's been paying her longer than they
were married.
Just want to just fucking jump off a
bridge,
but that's,
you know,
like I said,
negative fruit.
I just,
I don't see the upside.
Right.
What's so rare that it works out the
other way.
It's so rare that a woman has to pay a
man and it's one of those things where
it's like men are being victimized left
and right by this and when you talk to
people about their.
I was like,
Oh,
you will.
You fucked up.
Well,
you shouldn't have done it.
you should've got a prenup.
Well,
okay.
Maybe.
Maybe you could say all those things.
Yes,
maybe it was a mistake,
but it was obviously a mistake under
the,
the whole spell of love.
And to have this be a financial
entanglements that can trap you in this
one I'm talking about.
My friend doesn't even have any kids.
He didn't have any kids with this lady,
so it's,
it's insanity.
It's just,
it's just a robbery.
It's just a legalized robbery.
And I was having this conversation with
a buddy of mine who is married.
He's like,
wow,
you know,
I don't look at it that way.
I go,
look at it this way,
the the business of divorce and it is a
business.
Whenever there's money involved in
something,
there's a bunch of people that try to
figure out how to extract that money of
the lawyer.
The only money is in taking the money
from the rich guy.
That's where the money comes from.
That's the only way you get the money.
You don't get the money.
If the girl doesn't make much money and
everybody wins.
If the rich guy gets fucked.
So if the.
If the legal battle for the divorce last
two years as opposed to two minutes,
everybody gets paid.
The both lawyers on both sides make a
substantial amount of money.
The woman gets a substantial amount of
money.
The guy gets fucking drain like a
vampire and that's what happens
predominantly.
Yeah.
Which is usually the outcome of a lot of
times when a rich guy gets involved in
anything is yeah,
he gets drained and that's kind of goes
back to my previous point of why I feel
like women that are attracted to guys
that are successful,
you know,
it makes sense because there's just so
many people trying to take that
motherfucker down,
you know,
like when you're at the top of the hill,
like,
you know,
everybody wants to,
get out there and bringing it down while
it's nature.
I mean it's just like a moose having a
fucking giant set of antlers.
All the other moods.
Like,
oh,
look at those antlers.
And I mean it's just,
it is a thing that exists in all
different species.
I mean there's no,
there's no denying that.
When a guy pulls up in a Rolls Royce and
he flies into his own private jet,
he does a bunch of things that nobody
else can do,
that people just go,
oh,
and women automatically genetically get
attracted to that guy for some strange
reason.
There is you,
you are buddy bawling,
bawling,
out of control.
How did you get all your money
originally?
So that's another common misconception
and I didn't really,
I didn't really talk about it or,
or saying anything about it just because
it helped me out so much in poker.
Um,
but everybody just thought that I was,
you know,
rich trust fund,
idiot.
Um,
and then my parents gave me all my money
so that actually allowed me to get into
a lot of these poker games.
Um,
because they thought you were a fish.
Yeah,
it's like a weird thing.
Um,
it's not just that,
but in poker I've noticed that if a guy
loses money to another guy and he knows
that that money's going to,
that other guy out or his quality of
life is going to be improved by that
money.
It really fucking irritates them.
Like going.
Yeah.
And I'm guilty of it too.
If I lose $5,000,000
to a billionaire,
it doesn't bother me nearly as much as
if I lose maybe a couple hundred
thousand to some guy that's like pretty
broke.
And now he goes out and buys a new
fucking car with my money.
And I'm just like this fucking guy,
you know what I mean?
Like,
oh,
that's weird.
I don't know why and it,
and it's,
it's kind of counterintuitive,
you know.
But another thing about it is like if
you lose money to a guy that has a
bunch,
like you always think that,
you know,
there's a chance you could win it back
to.
So there's that piece of it.
Um,
if you lose money to a guy that doesn't
really have much and he goes out and
spends it will like,
you're never getting it back again.
Um,
yeah,
that exists in pool.
Like a lot of guys don't want to gamble
with guys only have one barrel.
Go play your game pool for 100 bucks,
but he's only got 100 bucks,
but they might have 10,000.
Exactly.
So you look at your upside,
it's like,
okay,
best case scenario,
walk away from this with this guy's last
hundred bucks,
which to me,
some guys get off on that.
To me,
I don't really ever want to break a guy.
Right?
But then you look at the d,
The downswing of that is like,
okay,
I could spend 10,000
trying to chase my initial hundred bucks
that I lost.
So you have to take that.
There's just a lot of things in gambling
that you've taken to account,
you know,
with the,
with the money management,
psychological things.
Yeah.
So how did you make your money then
playing poker?
He made it all playing poker.
Yeah.
Wow.
That is insane.
So what did you do for a living before
you played poker?
I mean,
I was in the military for four years.
Um,
and when I got out,
got honorable discharge,
I had,
you know,
uh,
I was getting some disability money from
the va just because I,
you know,
I got a lot of injuries when I was going
through buds and,
and just not even just injury,
just all the medical checks they do,
they just document all the things that
are wrong with you so you get a
percentage for all those things.
Kind of Shit was wrong with you.
Fuck,
I mean,
I first time I went in and I had a
bilateral stress fractures so I was,
you know,
went into bugs,
have broken legs and so I was eating a
bunch of motor and it burned a hole in
my stomach.
I had acid reflux.
They ended up getting so bad they were
actually going to kick me out of the
navy,
gone through buds with broken legs first
I went in.
Yeah.
And nobody knew that lecture sore.
Well no I got medically dropped the
first.
So I mean it's kind of a long story,
but I'll try and give you the cliff
notes.
Um,
so I went to bootcamp and the furthest
I'd ever ran was like two miles and it
was straight out of high school because
I got thrown in jail,
um,
my senior year of high school.
So I didn't graduate and get your ged.
Um,
and kids you don't need a degree.
Slim how to play poker.
Well we'll get to that.
So,
um,
end up joining the military,
go go through bootcamp in a school.
I was trying to ramp up.
So I'm like,
fuck,
I'm going to seal training.
I gotta I gotta start running.
So I started running,
I got an overuse injury,
turned into stress fracture a.
They basically put me on a medical hold
and my detailer said,
look,
you can stay on this medical hold
through,
your legs are healed and then I'm going
to send you to a ship for two years and
then you can apply or else you can get
cleared and go straight to seal
training.
So I was like,
okay,
got cleared.
When seal training,
they dropped me the first day I had to
request to talk to the captain and
finally the captain's like,
okay,
you know,
I'll let you,
I'll let you try it because I basically
said,
look,
just give me a shot.
I'm already here.
Like,
let me just train.
Um,
what's the worst that can happen?
I'm not going to die and you know,
break the leg worse.
So I said,
if I make it through hell week,
just give him medical role.
He's like,
yeah,
sure kid,
go ahead.
So the guy let me train.
Um,
that was actually first bet I made my
doctor who was like a Vietnam seal.
He's like,
he was so fucking pissed that the c CEO
allowed me to train.
And so he's like,
I'll bet you a hundred bucks you don't
make it through hell week is 100 bucks
or 20 bucks,
I forget which,
but I bet the guy and I won the fucking
money.
Um,
and three weeks after I was just,
I mean I could barely walk,
you know,
so I ended up getting enrolled and they
kicked me out.
Um,
and so I went to my ship and the ship
was like,
the captain of the ship wants to take me
out to see even though it's supposed to
be on crutches.
So I was like,
this motherfucker.
So after,
after going through like the hardest
thing and then getting dropped,
um,
now I'm on a boat and I was supposed to
be like healing up and this guy wants to
take me out at sea.
So go to Okinawa.
And I requested to go in to see my
wisdom teeth.
And then when I was there I was like,
hey,
you know,
check my legs and like,
okay,
we'll do a nuclear bone scan.
So when I was supposed to go in from an
they said,
you know,
come back in two hours.
So I went for a two hour run and in just
like my fucking,
not even like my,
uh,
fatigues.
It was like a work uniform.
It was like a button down shirt.
I wear a two hour run,
took a shower,
came back and he looked at my legs and
I'm like,
your legs are fucking destroyed.
Like I can't believe you can walk.
I'm like,
yeah,
these motherfuckers,
you know,
and so they're gonna kick me out of the
navy.
So it just like that was thing I was
going to get medically discharged from
the navy and it took them so long that I
actually requested to go back and I
just,
I'll never forget because I went in and
talked to the CEO of my,
it was like a limited duty security
detail or whatever.
And he goes,
let me get this straight.
He goes,
you're about to be medically retired
from the military.
He goes for broken legs and you want me
to request or approval requests for you
to go to seal training.
He goes,
how fucking stupid are you?
And I was just like,
and I didn't really know what to say.
I was or you know,
this is just like,
he's like,
get the fuck out of my office.
And I was like,
thinking about it,
I was like,
well fuck,
like I,
you know,
I'm like,
he'll have been doing steroids.
I feel great,
but fucking working out like,
well it's been like eight months,
right?
Like I feel like I could go do this
again.
So I ended up pulling some strings and
uh,
and basically I just had to get cleared
and then I had to pray that I got sent
to buds because if not it'll go to a
ship.
And then I had to.
It was just like,
it would be the biggest disaster of all
time.
So that was one of my biggest gambles
was doing that.
I'd like a free ride for the rest of my
life medically retired.
Like,
you know,
I'm a disabled veteran,
like,
you know,
all this great shit and I kinda like
gave it up to go back.
And um,
uh,
yeah,
I went into his office and he goes,
he goes,
you might be the stupidest motherfucker
I've ever seen.
He goes,
he goes,
you just better hope that you don't end
up back at this command.
He could see goes,
you're going to clean fucking toilets
until you get discharged.
And uh,
yeah.
So that was,
how would they have discharge?
How would they have paid you for life
from broken links?
I mean,
Delta legs heal up and then you're okay.
That's the thing is like,
it just,
it had been basically since it was
documented because when I got out of um,
bootcamp at a school,
I had them and I had them all through
buds.
Where is it broken?
A bilateral tibial stress fracture.
So my tip,
um,
and then that's the big one,
right?
The fibula is a smaller one.
Those in the shins.
I don't remember which,
but I think it was the very one.
Um,
and then so all through bonds and then,
you know,
on the boat.
So it was,
it was basically like,
you know,
I had broken legs for like a year and a
half or a year and seven months just
insane.
It was basically like,
they're like,
okay,
well this guy's legs are just never
going to fucking.
He'll right.
Like,
that was kind of like the military,
his take on it was like,
okay,
well he's been on limited duty like this
and that,
like his leg should have healed by now
and they just aren't,
so what are we going to do with them?
So why wasn't it healing?
I'm still confused because I went
through seal training that kind of
fucked them up a little bit and then,
you know,
I was on the boat and I wasn't allowed
to use crutches.
And then I think obviously the final
Straw was probably me fucking going on a
two hour run on a purpose.
Fuck yeah,
I did it on purpose.
Yeah.
But what was the goal of fighting to get
the fuck off the ship?
I said,
you know,
this capital was such a dickhead.
It's like Brah,
I went through all this fucking pain,
you know what I mean?
Like I went through seal training,
it's like letting my legs,
you know,
you fucking cock sucker.
Like the guy like wanted me to like
stand watches on the bus.
It was like Kinda like,
it's basically like a fuck you to him.
So you crushed her own legs to get off
the boat and then try to get into seal
training.
Yeah,
well it took them so long,
you know,
took them so long to process me out of
the military that they had healed.
And so I was like well fuck wow that's
hilarious.
So just from those broken links,
you could have been set up where you've
got a pension forever and not only that
but like if you're a disabled veteran
you get like a year eligible for a lot
of shit,
you know,
if you're like medically retired,
it's kind of like,
you know,
you went in the military,
he tried to,
you know,
be in there forever and like you just
got injured,
you know what I mean?
So they like make a lot of,
you know,
allowances for people like that.
Like I think they give you like your
first loan on your house for free.
There's like a whole bunch of Shit,
Huh?
Yeah,
I remember because I looked into it when
I gave it all up.
So then what happens then?
I'm so well then I went back into uh,
into bugs or field training or whatever.
Um,
and I,
uh,
I made it two days before graduation and
I got rolled all the way back the
beginning and then I did the whole
fucking thing again.
And why did you get rolled all the way
back to the beginning?
So when I went through the second time I
kind of had the attitude of just like,
fuck,
I've already done this shit and I just,
you know,
also,
I don't know,
I mean I was just in great shape and I
just,
I wasn't worried about anything.
So my attitude was like,
okay,
well worst case scenario I'm just going
to get beat and I don't really care.
So I just would,
I just figured if I passed everything
and I performed well and I didn't quit,
like they couldn't kick me out so I
kinda didn't really like kiss ass or
anything.
I was just like,
whatever,
like,
you know,
and if I fucked up it's like okay,
I'll get beat.
Like,
you know,
I was like pretty hard dude.
I've been trained for two years,
I'd already been through hell week and
now I'm doing it without broken legs,
you know,
like going through with broken legs now
I'm like,
he'll,
I'm like fuck,
you know,
like nothing could be bad now.
So it's like worth the worst that can
happen.
I'm,
we get hypothermia or I'm going to have
to do some pushups,
like whatever.
And so I just didn't really have a good
attitude.
I wasn't too worried about um,
like the other guys in the class because
I figured,
you know,
would lose Mosa.
I mean started off with 239 guys and we
came through hell week with like 34.
My first class we started with 119 and
we came through [inaudible] 17.
So you're like,
you're going to lose most of these guys.
I don't really.
I don't know.
I,
I mean,
I wasn't much of a team player.
I just want to graduate,
you know,
so.
So,
but how they kick you back then?
Well started,
I got one safety violation,
um,
uh,
for the instructor gave the wrong order.
We're on the range and we're facing down
range and he gave an about face and
drop.
So half the class just did with words,
you know,
we did the about face,
we drop and now we're like pointing down
range,
right?
So half the class got a safety violation
for that.
And then the second one was we were
doing I ads like these a live fire
drills and half the classes behind the
berm,
the other half was doing it and then we
switched and I was behind the berm and
my,
off my own berm was like a big mound of
dirt.
And My,
uh,
the officer in charge of my class,
he didn't really like me.
So he had me on watch every single night
and he put me on the Middle Watch.
So out on the island,
um,
you get six hours of sleep Max if you
fall asleep when you get off and then
you wake up the second and you don't
clean any of your gear,
you get six hours.
So he put me on us on a watch in the
middle,
so I got maybe like an hour in the
beginning and then I just wake up for
two hours for the watch and then maybe
if I could go back to bed I'd get like
an hour,
maybe two hours asleep.
So I was running on real low sleep and
um,
so I was behind the Berman.
I just,
you know,
I fell asleep.
It wasn't a big deal.
Most guys did.
But my crew leader didn't wake me up
because he didn't like me.
So now I'm technically sleeping during a
live fire drill because they did a class
muster up fucking sleeping as the guns
going off.
And you're sleeping.
Yeah,
I mean the other guys did too.
Yeah.
I mean we're just like,
we're sitting there because it,
it,
you know,
it's like 40 minutes something.
They're doing their shit and we're just
laying there,
we're not doing it.
We're not supposed to be involved or you
know,
were just,
they could only have half the class in
the range.
So half is just sitting there and then
the other half is doing it and fuck man.
Like,
I mean,
dude,
during hell week I fell asleep standing
up,
you know.
So it's like,
yeah,
you get tired enough,
you fall asleep like no matter what.
So.
So you came out of that.
So yes,
I got rolled all the way back.
So,
so basically they put me in front of the
thing and,
and uh,
and they're like,
well you got to safety violations,
whatever.
And I was just like,
you know,
I was like,
well,
I didn't really even explain.
I didn't even really like at the time
you're so brainwashed that these guys
are like gods.
You don't even really want to argue with
them because they instructors.
It's like you can't even like have a
conversation with these guys because
I've asked you a question.
Like,
your answers are like,
who you are.
Like you don't even say yes or no.
It's just like a,
you know,
so you're so like conditioned to not
argue that I didn't really like defend
what happened,
you know,
because if I were to like walk in there
and like defended like exactly like
look,
like half the class,
you know,
just given the explanation,
but I didn't really want to like argue
with these instructors because you're
just so brainwashed.
Anyways.
So I basically told him,
I said,
look,
you know,
I don't care.
I'll go do the whole fucking thing
again.
And they're like,
oh yeah.
I was like,
yeah.
oh,
I'll do the whole fucking course again.
So they rolled me all the way back and
did the whole fucking thing again.
And uh,
and this instructor that didn't like me,
he just,
he couldn't even find excuses.
The third time he just,
admin dropped me.
I didn't even know that was a good
thing.
I didn't know you could get admin drop,
but yeah,
I just cut
it,
made it all the way through.
Any admin dropped.
You haven't driven the stocks,
your instagram page right now?
I don't know,
but I think he remembers.
You have
probably,
yeah,
I mean he's probably heard of me now.
I mean the seal community is definitely
love or hate with me,
like you know,
the guys that know me usually,
you know,
have good things to say and the guys
that don't usually all talk shit but.
So you get out and then what happened?
So I get out.
I'm a diva for years.
Got Out and um,
I uh,
I went to college.
When did you,
and did four years there and uh,
my brother was like the military too.
It did four years.
Paid my dues.
I prison.
Yeah,
no it was,
it was fun.
I had a great time in college.
My brother taught me how to play poker.
I'm like the first year because I was
getting all this money from the Va and
the Gi bill and I got grants.
I was eligible for everything.
Right.
So that's what you learn how to play
poker.
Yeah.
My brother taught me and then I was
planning college is playing,
like some online stuff.
I had a couple of fraternity brothers
that were really into it and they taught
me a little bit and there's some home
games and yeah,
that's,
that's how I started.
I went broke,
um,
my sophomore year,
so I was just like,
it was a,
it was a wild ride.
I just sell some guns that went and
played on a gambling boat for like a
week and turned like this.
I sold three guns for 750 bucks,
played on this gambling boat for a week,
turned into 10,000,
went to Vegas and then turn that into
187,000
at Bellagio after playing for three
weeks straight.
Never forget it.
Wow.
So that was the launching point.
One hundred and 87,000
at the Bellagio.
Bellagio created Dan Bilzerian
essentially.
Yeah.
Well they started it.
So there you go and you just become this
crazy baller poker player character.
Well,
I mean it was a,
it was a slow rise,
you know,
I mean,
it wasn't.
How long did it take?
Oh,
I mean,
you know,
that was,
I was,
that was 2005.
You know,
and I actually,
I mean I got really lucky I came into
poker at a time when nobody really knew
how to play this fucking guy,
Chris moneymaker,
um,
you know,
he turned $25 into like a two or
$3,000,000
win and he wasn't even that great.
So it was like the new gold rush,
like everybody wanted to play poker
rounders had just come out,
you know,
that's what it was fucking movie.
I remember that.
It was that,
you know,
celebrity started playing and it was
just like,
it was one of those things were and
there wasn't really any like training
tools like the game hadn't been solved.
Like even the pros weren't that good
back then.
So really?
Yeah,
I mean there wasn't,
it was just kinda like,
I mean back in the day,
like the old pros,
the way they won,
they just cheated,
you know?
Really.
Yeah.
I mean there was a cheat.
Oh fuck.
I mean there's more cards,
there's cold backs,
there's a million ways.
I've never played poker.
I mean I might've played once in high
school or something like that.
I've never played my friend Ari,
Ari Shaffir,
he when he was struggling in Hollywood,
when he,
he's,
he's a stand up comedian and when he
wasn't,
was just starting out,
he would make his money playing poker,
go to poker tournaments,
and he made way more money playing poker
than he ever did.
Doing standup.
Yeah.
Actually,
I mean I'll tell you the story of how I
dropped out of college.
Can I piss real quick?
Good.
No worries man.
One Sec.
Go ahead.
Right here.
So I drank a bunch of water.
I just want to point out Dan Bilzerian
and I wear the same pants both wearing
camo pants.
I think he deserves it more than me
though.
He went to hell week.
I've just hidden from animals three
times,
but my pants are a.
they're fake.
I mean I just bought them on Amazon.
They're not like,
they're not like real cammo either.
It's something like,
cool.
You are first light or anything.
What a fucking character though.
Huh?
That's crazy shit.
Right?
Like a lot of people hate on that dude
ever.
I've met him a couple of times and it's
one of the reasons why I wanted to do
this one.
It seems like a super nice guy,
but every time I've talked to people
about them,
there was a food third good food,
good food.
The course,
of course.
I mean,
he's like all.
I mean the fact he's not paying those
girls that I find that suspicious.
Do you find that suspicious?
We don't.
Not really.
I mean,
why are they there then?
Because they can get.
They don't have shit to do.
Don't they have jobs?
They're hot.
Probably he loans the money.
Let's leave some cash around.
Can Be.
Doesn't sure.
They're getting good gigs out of it.
I'm sure they're getting good gigs out
of it.
I mean,
look what the fuck's that guy's named
Corey Feldman.
He's Feldman's angels or whatever the
fuck that is.
Right?
Hugh hefner had this.
The halfs have like show for awhile.
Well,
the he had to pay.
Those girls were talking about a
haffner.
They're all playing.
Maybe that was,
that was sad to me.
That was more sad to me.
Was that the Haffner thing?
Like,
uh,
I could see chicks to bang you.
Handsome guy,
thick beard,
built no military man,
got a lot of guns.
That makes sense.
The after thing was always like,
oh,
those poor girls,
I have daughters and I would,
I would think about some poor girl and
Hugh hefner and just going,
oh
yeah,
but it's not just him.
It's Kinda like all these fashion guys.
Fashion guys.
Yeah.
Like,
I mean,
you know,
Paul Marsianno,
he bangs every check this and gas,
you know.
Oh yeah,
okay.
Yeah.
So I mean it's Kinda like they set it
up,
right?
Like,
I mean,
my whole thing is kind of like life
setup,
right?
So you set up your life to where you
don't really have to work for what you
want,
right.
So,
um,
you know,
push for instance,
like if you set it up correctly,
like I mean if you buy a big brand or a
modeling agency or whatever it is,
and you're providing these girls with a
career,
like for instance,
let's,
let's use Hugh Hugh hefner.
So if you become a playmate,
you're guaranteed $25,000.
Um,
you now you're,
I mean this is back in the day,
right,
there's like,
you know,
10 years ago and playboy was hot or you
know,
20,
whatever,
so now they're getting a thousand
dollars for appearance before they were
getting,
you know,
whatever,
but now they won't,
you know,
you can't even show up for less than a
grand through your guaranteed more money
there.
Now you have a title,
um,
as far as modeling,
like you're just going to book higher
end jobs.
There's,
you know,
there's the playboy events,
so it's Kinda like,
you know,
it's like you fuck this guy,
he'd be home playmate and now you like
have a career.
Oh,
I get it.
It makes sense and I mean it makes
sense,
but the factor that's missing is the
fact that you were talking about before,
like you're not really into fucking
girls that aren't into you,
you know,
that's completely out of the downside of
the question.
Yeah.
When you're a skeleton,
you.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
When you're a scale.
Yeah.
But I mean,
when you're a skeleton,
like what are you going to do
your ball and you just take molly and
fucking throw down those Viagra is get
the party started.
Who gives a shit?
Throw that money out.
You can't spend it when you're dead.
Yeah.
What up 70.
I'm probably going to be less picky,
you know,
so.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
But I mean,
like I said,
it's,
it's you go for a hot 50 year old,
but you know,
who knows,
some of those girls might be into it
because he's,
you know,
he's iconic and you know,
fuck a celebrity thing.
Celebrity is another crazy thing.
I mean I've,
I've said it to my buddy,
I'm like,
money maybe brings five or 10 x girls,
like if you use it and I'm going to talk
about using it in the sense of just
paying them saying like set up your life
to where they're given a nice life and
there's cool shit going on.
Parties,
whatever.
And then the fame I think,
I think it's like a hundred X.
I think it's like a hundred times.
Well you,
it's very
interesting because you're a guy that's
just come into this just a few years
ago,
four years ago,
you know,
so you were already a man in his
thirties and all this happened and then
boom,
you become famous.
So you've got a good perspective on it,
you know,
I think for people looking at it on the
outside,
like I don't think any of us could
understand what it'd be like to be
drake.
You know,
I've heard that drake has parties at his
house.
I know dude who lives near Drake and he
complains about the fucking parties and
the parties are so crazy that the
neighbor complaints at drake bought his
house drinks like,
fuck it,
I'll just buy your house,
man.
He has girls.
They meet at one place,
then they get in a bus and then the bus
comes to drake's house.
Now he's,
he's got it.
Yeah.
He's definitely has it on the level.
Super Baldwin for Super Bowl and you,
you know me,
I'm fucking saddled down.
I'm married.
I've got kids.
I've got daughters too.
Dude.
I see all this stuff I have to watch
from afar and go,
wow,
look at this action with all this
craziness happening,
look at this.
Wildlife just had a completely different
kind of life.
But to um,
to be a guy like you,
it's very interesting because not only
are you're famous,
you're famous in a,
like a really confusing way.
You're famous just for being a baller,
like 100 percent.
Like it's Kinda crazy.
I didn't write a book.
You're not in any movies,
you don't sing any songs.
You're not telling jokes.
You just balling out of control your
ball and so hard that you become famous.
You way more famous than me.
I mean,
what did you say you have?
How many instagram followers you got?
What is it?
Nineteen 18.
I think the total is 31.
One point five on instagram.
I have a two one on twitter.
I've been on TV for 20 fucking years.
It's funny man.
It's an interesting kind of fame.
It's a very different kind of fame.
Yeah,
I mean I just remember,
I remember when it Kinda hit me because
I was in
can and I
was over there and this,
you know,
this is,
this is France and then they don't only
speak English a lot of these places
and I mean
I think what was I fuck 16 girls and
it's 12 days and I remember because I
fucked a girl without talking to her and
that was when I talked to her.
Yeah,
because she didn't speak English and
they're.
And I also like,
I just kinda like wanted to like just
see if I could do it,
you know,
I just like wanted to see if I could
actually have sex with a girl without
speaking to her at all.
It was kind of awkward because like
there's Times that I wanted to say
something or like there was a question
asked or whatever,
like,
you know,
or it was like in the middle of sex,
like norma,
like I'll say you have to talk dirty or
something.
But like I made a point to be a fucking
mute.
Right.
And I actually like pull it off and I
was like,
wow,
like this shit is real,
you know,
and,
and the time that I really saw it as a.
sorry,
let me,
it was,
I mean,
I was in Canada.
Is before the,
the no talking thing.
I was at some restaurant and raw Ron
Perlman's manager came over to me and
he's the actor.
Yeah.
Sons of anarchy.
Hellboy in hell,
that's a real shit,
you know,
he's a real dude.
So he come over and he's telling me
about this new movie that he wants to do
and there's like a,
um,
there's a dad and there's a son or
grandfather's grandfather,
son and dad and they're all,
they're all in the military in different
wars.
And he was talking to me about maybe
playing the son and,
and we're having,
you know,
and I was interested in it because I'd
done a little bit of acting up until
then.
And so it was like,
you know,
kind of,
trying to,
you know,
check it out.
And so I remember it was like every 30
seconds or minutes somebody would come
up and ask you for a picture and after
like the 20th person,
somebody came up and was like,
oh Ron,
like,
you know,
I love a picture with you and I'll never
forget it.
I'll never forget for the rest of my
life.
He stood up and he goes,
oh,
you want a picture of me?
Like,
who the fuck am I?
You sure you don't want a picture of
this guy?
And he was kidding.
But I was just like,
I was like,
wow,
like this is so fucking crazy.
Now here's a guy that's like,
you know,
a super successful actor has been like,
big like tv series and like all these
people are asking to take a picture with
me.
And I was just like,
wow,
like this is so fucked up.
But it was real.
I was just like,
wow,
this is like a real thing.
This isn't just like numbers on the
Internet.
This is like I'm in a foreign country
and I got all these fucking people
coming up.
I was,
I was kinda like,
I was dumbfounded.
Have you ever
read that thoreau quote?
Most men live lives of quiet
desperation.
Yeah,
actually quoted that in one of my
pictures.
Oh,
that's a great quote.
The massive men or something along the
lines of the mass of men lead lives of
quiet.
Something along those lines.
That quote,
fucking died.
Love that quote.
That's got a lot of great ones.
He's a brilliant,
brilliant guy,
but that quote is that one of the
reasons why I think your instagram and
everything is so popular is because
there's a lot of people out there that
are stuck in cubicles or they're stuck
in jobs that they don't want to be
there.
They don't want to be doing what they're
doing.
They're looking at the resources.
They're so small,
they're tired all the time.
They get done from work.
They don't have any energy to do
anything else.
They're saddled down with some
relationship is probably not optimal to
getting yelled at the fucking.
It's not going well.
There's not a lot of joy.
And then they go on your instagram and
your fucking jet skiing and lake mead
and so all the,
you know,
shooting guns and your underwear and
it's like,
it's.
So it looks so fun,
you know?
And
yeah,
I mean I try and be authentic,
you know,
another one of his quotes,
rather than love rather than fame rather
than money Gimme truth.
And I liked that to have all those
though.
Look,
you got it all.
You got to truth.
You've got fame.
We got drugs,
heroin and la.
Well it is,
it is rare because it's difficult to
pull off because most people are not
really comfortable with who they are.
So instead of,
you know,
instead of fixing that,
they just kinda pretend you know,
and like,
look,
that's what politics is.
That's what a business is.
When you put that fucking stupid tie on
and he got those slippery shoes with the
tassels on them and pretending that you
really talk like that.
You know,
when you're talking about dividends and
making them know that we can make this
work and let's touch base on Monday and
way.
Great to talk to you and like shut the
fuck up
or correctness,
the fucking pleasant trees that just the
bullshit,
you know,
that's what I wanted to just kind of
get rid of.
I had a conversation with someone about,
you know,
people that have a lot of money and
ballers and someone goes,
uh Oh,
that seems like such an empty life.
And I don't know if we were talking
about you specifically,
but you're like a perfect example of it.
I'm like,
but here's my point.
I'm defending you.
I'm like,
what's empty about?
It looks like he's having fun.
Like,
what's so great about showing up to an
insurance company every day and putting
in your work like,
yeah,
look,
it's very admirable to provide for your
family.
It's very admirable to put in hard work
when you don't want to and get it done.
But there's nothing wrong with figuring
out a way to not do that either.
You know?
Just because you got stuck in some sort
of a weird situation where you have to
fucking grind it out at some lumber yard
every day.
Doesn't mean that a guy like you who's
just got some crazy life that he's lived
and where he figured out a way to make a
bunch of money,
gambling poker,
playing card games like that's not,
it's not necessarily a bad thing.
Like I look at all your shit.
I don't see any victims.
I don't see anything wrong.
I see you having a bunch of fun and I
see a bunch of girls that are laughing.
They seem to be having a bunch of fun.
You're flying to Italy,
you're doing all this crazy shit.
I don't see anything wrong but yet
people get mad and people hate.
And when I have conversations with
people and Mike,
what is shallow about all these
experiences?
Like what is,
what is so awful?
Yeah.
I mean,
and a lot of girls have really
benefited,
you know,
build some careers.
Like,
you know,
Lindsay polyps.
When I started dating her,
she had a 100,000
followers.
She bumped up the one point $6 million
and three weeks and now this chick's
making poor $500,000
a year posting pictures on instagram and
snapchat.
I mean,
just just think about that for a second,
like she's making four times as much as
a doctor or a lawyer when they get out
of college and,
and,
and forget about all their debt that
they have,
you know,
let's just say they come out of college
with no debt.
She's still making five times more money
than them at four years younger.
Well also the amount of fucking time
they have to spend if you're a doctor or
a lawyer,
not just going through medical school,
not just going through your residency
but working,
constantly working and she's got a post,
a couple pictures.
Sit on a couch,
post a few pictures.
She stuck her by t her ass up in the
air.
High heels.
Ooh.
It's beautiful world.
The world of social media is a
fascinating world man because like
speaking for me personally as a,
as a comedian before social media,
I used to have to do so much work.
I used to have to get up early in the
morning and do radio shows before gigs.
I used to have to do morning TV.
You'd have to do interviews with,
you know,
I do an interview with some newspaper
reporter if that guy did not want to
fucking talk to me and give a shit about
me and try to have fun with it and maybe
he would try to have fun with it,
but for the most part it was nonsense.
You don't have to do any of that
anymore.
Social media,
it's just pure uh,
access and it's,
it's actually fucked it up honestly for
a lot of these girls now because they
don't want to go to the clubs.
Like they don't need to go to parties
and meet celebrities anymore.
They could just dm him like,
and then you have all these rich guys
that are just having their,
you know,
their pussy coordinator,
message all these ordinator Oh,
who has a court,
was a pussy coordinator.
Crazy Bro.
You have no idea.
Like now these girls are getting booked
out there,
getting paid $5,000,
$10,000
to just go on a vacation.
Some of them don't even have to sleep
with any of the guys.
I mean,
it's just like,
that seems like you would never get
anything done.
Yeah,
I mean,
and,
and from these girls' point of view,
you can't really blame them and it's
like,
fuck,
if I was one of these girls and I could
travel the world on a private jet and do
all this other crazy shit for free and
it's just.
I mean,
I don't
blame them at all as long as long as
nothing awful is happening.
Yeah.
I used to know this guy,
we call him wild man.
A buddy of mine used to work at a strip
club.
He was a DJ at a strip club and there
was a guy there that apparently invented
bell bottoms is a crazy story and he had
lung cancer.
He smoked cigarettes like packs and
packs a day and no emphysema.
And his doctor was telling him,
listen man,
you are going to fucking die if you
don't stop smoking cigarettes.
You're gonna fucking die.
And he's like,
I'm just addicted to smoking.
It was like smoke joints.
He's like,
they're,
they've shown in studies that smoking
marijuana is not nearly as bad for you.
And actually it might act as an
expectorant it might help clean your
lungs out even though it sounds contrary
to,
to logical thinking.
Just give it a try.
So this guy starts smoking weed,
like he would smoke cigarettes.
You just roll in joint smoking.
He would smoke like 15,
20 joints a day.
And he would,
when he pull up to the Strip club,
he would give these guys like his
roaches because there's roaches were
like half done because he would smoke
them,
smoke cigarettes.
The guy changes his entirely.
He gets so high and he's so high all the
time.
He's like,
I don't want to do any of these things
that I'm doing anymore.
He goes,
this is one on one,
do I want to play guitar?
And I want a bank checks.
And that's when he decides to do.
He realizes he's like 60 years old and
he's worth some shit,
ton of money.
And this was like right around when
Viagra was invented.
So this guy goes on a rampage and he's.
But he's mean,
he's like really nasty.
And he did what he would call mad dog in
these chicks.
So He'd bring them back to his house and
he would say nasty shit to him and hit
him and piss on him and all kinds of
crazy shit.
Apparently,
I don't know the full details of it,
but his house was for sale and he had
this ball baller house in the Hollywood
hills and for awhile I was thinking
because I go to the comedy store all the
time,
I'm like,
man,
maybe I should buy this fucking house.
It's like it's close to the comedy
store,
but I'm like,
God,
it's like this $5,000,000
house.
It's right on the street.
It's right there.
Like you could use the sidewalk and then
here's his door.
Like you just touch his door and like
someone's gonna fucking break into this
guy's house.
And so the realtor is like,
no,
listen,
there's a state of the art security
system in this place.
It's got all these cameras.
I go,
yeah,
you know what that camera's going to
get.
It's going to get a picture of a dude
with a ski mask robbing your fucking
house.
Like,
do you understand that?
Like what is,
what is a camera going to do?
Like how's it going?
Two weeks after I said that the dude got
shot in the neck,
in the fucking house he brought.
He used to bring the hookers to his
house.
He used to bring them to his house and
he brought one to his house and she
brought her boyfriend and they shot him
in the neck.
Wow.
Yeah.
There's a lot of setup,
stuff like that.
Yeah.
But.
So they see that's a bad guy.
That was a guy doing bad shit.
I don't see anything wrong with anything
you're doing.
I see.
I see happiness.
I look at your instagram.
I see a bunch of people laughing.
I liked the music you're playing.
You're playing
songs that I would listen to.
It looks like a fucking party.
Nothing wrong here.
People need to relax.
Yeah,
I mean I'm just know doing some wish.
Fulfillment.
Now,
do you have like,
do you have a like a plan,
chart it out for this existence?
Are you just winging it?
Well,
I got this APP coming out,
um,
where it's going to be kind of similar
to like what World Star does,
where you can,
users can upload,
you know,
they're bad ass videos,
right.
So anything kind of like,
you know,
similar to the stuff that I post or you
know,
fights or whatever crazy cool videos
that they want they can post on there
and you know,
I'll just share the best ones on my
facebook or instagram or whatever.
So they're,
you know,
if they post cool shit on there,
they're guaranteed to get,
you know,
a view on a shine.
Yeah.
And that's why they post on Worldstar,
you know,
because they want people to see it.
So I'm,
I'm,
you know,
I'm going to do that.
I got this,
a fantasy betting app that I got a,
it's a,
you know,
it's like similar to the draft kings of
the fantasy sports stuff.
Um,
I know just,
you know,
I've been focusing more on doing some
stuff like that.
I've Kinda just done everything I wanted
to do,
you know,
and you know,
as far as like the partying and shit,
you know,
so.
Well that's why I was asking him like,
well how much more can you do,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean I've checked most of the boxes
man.
So now I kinda just want to give people
a platform to how much money have you
made playing poker?
I don't know.
I mean if you had to guess in the
neighborhood.
I mean,
I know,
I mean I,
you know,
I just know the big figures,
right?
You know,
it'd be one guy for $54 million.
I mean I won 10 and a half and another
night I've been another guy for 10 and
then you know,
I don't know what the total is on the
other cash games but you know,
I dunno,
I know made a lot.
But do you have enough stashed away?
That was,
that was just an,
you know,
a six month or a year period.
So it's like a,
you know,
I don't know.
Did you take a chunk and put it away and
say,
okay,
this is my break glass in case of
apocalypse fund.
Okay.
Oh good.
I've bought bathrooms goal then,
you know,
and I,
and I own my stuff,
my plan and my house and my car.
Then I cash in the bank.
I'm doing all.
Yeah,
but I mean this,
like this.
First of all,
that's crazy,
right?
It's crazy that you went from being a
navy seal to being a college student
who's learning to play cards,
you know,
preparing or trying to attempt to be a
navy seal,
going to college and learn how to play
cards to a guy who's got his own fucking
jet.
Got It all from gambling.
I mean,
that's,
that's bizarre in and of itself.
But do you ever think like there's a
time where I'm not going to want to do
this anymore?
Yeah,
I mean,
I'm,
you know,
I'm kind of at the point,
like I said,
where I've done most of the stuff that I
wanted to do.
Um,
so now I'm just,
I'm kind of winging it.
I've been doing more active stuff.
I've been doing,
uh,
like some wake surfing and we went out
to Lake Powell and um,
you know,
winter's coming up and doing some
snowboarding trips.
Snowmobile and just more fun.
Yeah,
just haven't bombed but doing like more
active stuff.
Less party and mean self,
the girls around.
But um,
yeah,
I mean I got,
I did a cartoon.
It's a,
I'm about to,
didn't you have two heart attacks and
like one night or something.
That's actually one of the cartoon
episodes happen.
How did you have to.
Hard to get out the car theater.
Do you have the cartoon?
Watch it,
throw the Cartena how do we,
how do we get to it until Jamie gets A.
Yeah,
I'm sure you could drop a day,
Jamie,
or do you have it on your phone?
Is that what it is?
It's on my phone.
Oh,
can you,
can you airdrop it to you?
Jamie?
Does that work?
Uh,
I can't airdrop it,
but I can airplay it if you've got an
apple TV.
We have an apple tv but we can't play it
online vs watching it in here.
We can hear it or anything.
I can't put it on that.
You can,
but I don't have that.
That's not the system here.
It's not built into this display.
Um,
let me see.
Can we fix that?
Can we make that happen or is that we
can in the future,
but we need a different setup or
something.
I need some extra inputs.
Yeah,
we'll do it another time.
I'm going to call my guy and see if I
can get you a link you want to give me.
Give me one second.
Yeah,
yeah.
Good.
Call Your Guy Dan Bilzerian,
but we'll be right back.
Ladies and gentlemen,
he's gonna.
Call his guy.
Not to be confused with this pussy
coordinator.
He doesn't have one of those.
Are you looking for pussy coordinator?
I know some dudes look crazy.
Life Bizarre,
right?
I just,
you know,
people,
people will tell you that's going to get
tired.
We guess what?
So it was being married to a lot of
people,
not to me.
Jamie.
So is working in a regular job that's
got to be tired too.
I love the fact that this is a real
thing that all of a sudden because of
social media,
some guy can gather up 50 million
followers,
be continent,
I don't know how to word this right?
But like,
you know,
people start calling the Michael Jordan.
You'd be the Michael Jordan of this
because you're the greatest of whatever
he's starting to become.
People are calling so and so the Dan
Bilzerian of,
of X.
Oh yeah,
well that becomes so intense that
Italian guy,
juvenile vaccine,
the,
Oh,
that old guy is my age.
Isn't that sad?
God Damn,
I'm old.
Pro Sad.
Every now and then I wake up and I got
some new pain and uh,
I just think it's this pain like forever
is this going to heal here,
this hip thing that's going on lately?
And it's not bad.
Like I did kickboxing today and no
problem,
no pain while I'm working out,
but every now and then it irritates me
and instead of it,
like when I was young,
if I had something that irritated me,
I would say,
Eh,
some fucking nothing.
I'll get over that.
But that's also why I developed a bunch
of chronic injuries from Jujitsu because
I would go and train even though it had
something fucked up.
It's also because Jujitsu is really fun,
but I don't think like that anymore.
Man.
Now I think,
is this like broken?
Like is this,
am I going to need a hip replacement?
Like I know guys that are my age that if
a fucking.
I know guys younger than me that have
had hip replacements.
I started thinking like,
is this shit broken forever?
You got your guy.
I talked to him.
He's telling me I can't.
I can't show it.
You can't always tell who the fuck is
that guy.
So you've got a guide that tells you
what to do.
Saying,
dude,
I'm available.
I worked for free.
Pretty much fire them all.
I have a team to.
I don't listen to them either.
Nobody should listen to teams.
I mean,
I obviously don't know shit about poker.
I don't know nothing about your
business.
I'm not a Gambler,
but I can advise you.
Fire the whole to fire everybody.
Keep doing exactly what you're doing.
Listen to me,
dude.
I'm telling them right.
I have no experience in your business.
I'm totally unqualified,
but I will give you a,
some sound advice.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
that Italian guy that people keep
comparing to you,
the guy who dances around a lot.
Oh,
seeing them.
Yeah.
Some health issue.
What's going on?
Really?
I thought so,
but I don't know if that was the last I
had heard.
Oh,
I didn't hear that.
What's his name?
Giovanni vaccine or something like that.
Why I became aware of him because it was
a hilarious video of him and his
girlfriend dancing.
Oh yeah.
That's great.
Really good.
Fucking great.
But this thing,
here's the thing man.
Everybody's like,
I saw this thing like something about
sugar daddy and she's young and hot and
he's got gray hair that motherfuckers my
age,
like that's how old I am doing.
Forty nine.
The end is near.
The end is near Jamie.
There is no,
it looks great.
Yeah.
Well it's just the air.
I mean if he had black hair he would
look a little bit younger.
Right?
Oh,
for sure.
I mean he just has premium.
I have a buddy monitor thirties.
Here's almost all white.
I mean it's just some.
Some dudes are premature hair and he's
got a and girlfriend.
He's got one C,
you can't call them the Dan Bilzerian of
Italy.
I mean he's obviously a baller.
He's living guide.
I was bawling.
Just got one girl.
Yeah,
I mean I'm sure he's happy.
He looks very happy.
She looks very happy.
Everybody looks happy.
I be like,
he's doing a lot of stuff or instagram,
like he's posted a lot.
Just trying to get on that.
Dan Bilzerian level picky.
He at with levels yet $5 million.
How many giant jump.
He's done
twice as many posts as I've done in the
last five years and he's done it and I
think like six bucks.
Yeah,
very quickly.
Say he's posting a lot.
Well not only that,
his shit became a really popular like
really recently,
like I want to say when I became aware
of them,
we only have 2 million followers,
but like if you look at his stuff
though,
it Kinda looks like,
you know,
like a lot of photo shoots.
Right,
exactly.
How it looks like a lot of stage.
Oh look,
I found a goat.
Yeah,
look,
it's me with the goat.
Yeah.
He's,
he's got a lot of money.
Look at that.
Come on.
So that doesn't just accidentally
happened,
right?
Yeah.
You don't just accidentally get
photographed on a horse with no shirt
on.
White with prison tattoos.
What's what?
All the prison tattoos got like a bunch
of writing on his chest.
Was that all say?
Do we notice tattoos?
Say there must be like a website
dedicated to his chest.
Tattoos.
Look,
he's there with pit bull.
there he is.
Come on.
He's so happy now.
I mean it looks great.
It looks like a cool cat.
He does what?
He's doing his beard though.
That little thing that he puts at the
bottom of his beard.
He twists it up and puts like a little
rubber band around it.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Fuck.
That is.
I will pull that thing off.
I see you sir.
I'm going to grab that thing.
That's Goddamn handle.
I don't understand that.
Yeah,
he's A.
He's a fun cat though.
His videos are really fun.
No,
the fucking guy can dance.
Oh Man.
Did she pulled it?
See if you can find that one video of
him with the girl.
The first one they did on the boat that
got them really famous.
I want to say that was only four or five
months ago and I've really
in the last like five months he's really
like,
he's gone hard like.
But there's some stuff.
I mean it's like he set up a dinner
table.
I saw a picture.
He set up a dinner table underwater
where he could like pretend like he was
eating under water and then he did like
a whole,
like a whole skit where he was like,
underwater doing all this.
I'm like,
fuck man,
that must have taken you like fucking
full day.
Like he's wearing a suit.
Well,
he's gone a different approach.
Yeah.
Instead of the baller approach,
like shooting guns in his underwear,
what he's doing is he's got like this
one beautiful girlfriend.
They just have a good time all over the
world.
It seems.
I'm an,
it's a,
it's a different approach.
But
here's the by like that.
I did that.
Like this.
That's it.
No,
that's awesome.
I mean this mother fucker can dance.
He can.
He can fuck.
And he looks like he's having a good
time.
Not One hundred percent
that,
that.
That's cool.
To me.
They're like the other stuff that's
like,
it seems like lot of effort put into
it is not,
not quite,
but that.
That's dope.
I mean chick seems cool,
bumbling and dance.
Looks like he's having fun.
I mean like,
listen,
if you got that kind of money,
why wouldn't you be dancing?
She'd be dancing.
Has Awesome.
Should be partying.
You're fucking.
And he is just.
I don't understand his tattoos.
I'm confused about the ankle one.
What's going on down there?
Maybe it like his ex wife's name.
Like fuck you.
Bitch isn't good shape though.
Yeah,
he is.
Fuck you.
Yeah,
he's in very good shape for 49 year old.
That's my age.
Goddammit.
I'm fucking 49,
man.
It's just the end is near.
Know you're in the right time timeframe.
I'll tell you what it is.
They got the stem cells.
They got the hang of it all of,
all the above.
Oh yeah man.
Stem cells fix my fucking shoulder.
Like people are tired of hearing about
it.
On this podcast,
was that Regena kind or was that.
I had regeneca and on my shoulder to
help as much.
I had some pretty significant tearing.
I'm a slap tear.
I had a tear of the,
um,
the labor room,
a tear of the biceps tendon and a tear
of the rotator cuff.
I did the rotator cup.
I basically,
I couldn't even lift my arm like three
inches.
I did the REGENECA and then three weeks
later I was boxing like,
well Regina,
Regina kind did wonders for my back.
It just wasn't enough for my shoulder.
Again.
I'm an idiot.
I don't give it enough time off.
But uh,
when I was,
I,
I mean I literally from like this,
three weeks later I was boxing like,
yeah,
it is amazing.
Aggressive,
right?
I mean,
by all the doctors told me I needed
surgery.
Same thing to me.
Not that I've had that said to me twice.
I need surgery on my neck and I've heard
I need surgery on my shoulder.
I avoided both of them and I do
everything now,
but one of the things about shoulder
injuries that I've found from Steve
Maxwell,
he's a pretty famous,
a strength and conditioning coach has
been on this podcast a bunch of times,
is a hanging hanging from Chin up bars.
It's,
it's so important to do.
It's so good for your shoulders to
straighten out your shoulders.
You're going to say bad.
I was like,
fuck done.
A lot of that,
so it's really good for you.
There's a whole video about it with his
doctor who was a shoulder surgery
doctor,
stopped doing shoulder surgery on most
of his patients and started them on
this.
This hanging therapy,
because when you see most human human
beings,
essentially we're primates and most
primates swing from trees.
I mean that is what they do.
They grab a hold of things and they
swing and it stretches out your arm and
you develop impingements from gravity
from a lack of use or from too much use
or overuse,
and this guy has you hang from a chin up
bar,
just just holding on and hanging and it
stretches out your shoulder and it
alleviates pain in a giant percentage of
people that have shoulder injuries and I
urge anybody who's listening to this
that has any sort of shoulder weirdness
or some shit that fucks with them to
just try this.
I know it sounds crazy like how the fuck
is hanging by your shoulders going to
help you and this is one doctor that.
This is not the doctor that invented the
procedure,
but he basically explains it really
well.
There's a bunch of them.
What did you google so people can
shoulder pain hanging from a bar and
there's a lot of things that start
popping up as there's a gang of it,
but it's super effective.
It's super effective for a lot of
people.
I mean if you have significant tearing
where you're going to need surgery of a
failure of your joint or something like
that,
you know,
that's one thing.
But for a lot of people this offers them
a great deal of relief and it really
helps me.
I do it every day.
It's one of the first things I do in the
morning.
I hang and then I do a scapular raises
for archery.
So I hang.
I'll do like two minutes of hanging and
then once I've done two minutes,
then I just,
I contract my scapula and I hold that in
place for as long as I can.
So it's like my hands are given out,
my forms are given out and then I forced
my scapula to carry all the weight.
And you make it a daily routine.
Just make it is what I do.
I brush my teeth,
I do that.
I just have to do it.
So I'm forcing myself.
I have zero pain,
zero pain in my shoulders.
But the stem cells was a
factor.
So now are you getting the infusion or
are you getting the like how,
how,
how are you getting it?
Like I said earlier?
Yeah.
Um,
well they,
what they do is they take it from a
woman,
a young woman who's had a Sicilian
section when they give birth through
Assyrian section,
they take the placenta and then they use
that for stem cells and that apparently
is the most powerful version of stem
cell therapy.
There's a bunch of different kinds of
they use in this country that a lot of
people,
like a lot of people like it.
When they take your fat out,
they take your fat out and they convert
that stem cells and I brought into that.
But Daniel Cormier,
they went into his hip.
They got his marrow.
Yeah.
I got,
I got a 19 year old bone marrow
from someone else.
Okay.
Daniel Cormier,
they went into his own hip and pulled it
out.
But I've heard great results from a lot
of different versions of stem cells.
But I know for me personally,
when they shot the stuff from placenta
and in my shoulder,
it was like within a couple of weeks it
was better than it had been in a year.
And then a few months after that I was
like,
no pain.
It's amazing how quick it's healed.
And also did a lot of shoulder exercises
with rubber bands and stuff.
A lot of different things that I
concentrate on.
I do all the time now to strengthen up
the area and keep it tight.
But you haven't done the,
uh,
the Ivs.
So you did that?
Huh?
I've done that twice.
Last route and did that.
He told me that it was like he goes,
it was like the power was coming out of
my hands.
It's pretty crazy.
I mean,
I basically,
it was weird though,
the first time I did it,
it seemed like I had a lot more profound
effect on the second but the first time.
So I went down to Mexico because you
can't do it in the US.
So I went down there and got like $90
million,
uh,
of the 19 year old bone marrow oxygen
deprived or whatever,
and they injected in you.
Um,
the next day I went to get some dental
work done and they got a root canal or
whatever it was,
but they injected 25 vials of like lie
to Canaan,
Novacane and whatever it is.
And they said that my body was just
cycling through like instantaneously.
Right.
So I had all this dental work done the
next day I was completely healed from
all the dental work,
which is pretty crazy.
Yeah.
And they said they've never given
anybody that much lighter cane ever.
Um,
even,
you know,
and,
and they're like,
you know,
the guy asked me if I do coke and I'm
like,
no,
I haven't done that since I was 25.
He said,
yeah,
he's like,
normally like nobody can,
you know,
needs this much unless they have some
kind of a thing.
And I'm like actually normally really
drug sensitive.
I also found that um,
because I do a,
uh,
hrt and I found that when I did the
shots like I,
it was like a lot of people listening to
hormone replacement therapy.
Yeah.
And um,
and so basically I found that it just
cycled all these drugs faster through my
system so I'd get a stronger effect but
then it be out.
Um,
and then I went to the gym.
They said you're not supposed to work
out for three days or whatever.
I went to the gym,
I think it was like four or five days
later and I was like 20,
I think 20 percent stronger and I mean
I've been training for 20 something
years of done everything.
So to get like 20 percent strength in
Greece is just fucking crazy.
I'm going to Mexico.
It was so part of Mexico.
Where do you go?
Exactly?
I had an address Tijuana.
He it so dangerous.
It was like,
it was like Mario had,
I had like the armored cars.
I like made them give me a machine gun.
I was like,
I had like a machine go,
you want to your own machine going down
there.
She just,
in case shit goes down.
You don't want these guys to get shot
that place like the wild west man,
you know,
at least I'm going out.
I want to have a gun,
you know,
Tiwan,
it seems to me like,
yeah,
it's the wild west,
but they don't want to fuck it up
because there's,
the money's made all through tourism.
Like if somebody gets gunned down or
kidnap,
nobody wants to go to Tijuana.
So you rarely hear about anything going
down in Tijuana except those drugs.
Murders.
Yeah.
That was just the last ones with those
beheadings which were,
that was like a decade.
Pretty gnarly shit.
I,
I mean,
I just know that they didn't want me to
fly my plane down there.
I did anyways.
But they're like,
yeah,
you should probably show and you know,
there's probably drive you drive.
Not that long.
Uh,
I don't know.
Last time I went,
I mean I hadn't been down there since
the military,
but she seemed like the border crossing
going back just took forever.
It's a nightmare and now they want you
to.
I mean,
I don't know,
it just it back in the day it was easy.
We used to walk across the license.
Yeah,
yeah.
Driver.
Yeah.
That's.
When did he make it a passport?
Things Canada too,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well Canada has been like that,
but Mexico I think you said not be like,
or maybe Canada used to be licensed when
I used to go to Montreal is to know
you're right.
You're right.
Because I used to go fishing trips with.
Yeah.
So I don't know.
I don't know how long ago it was,
but they definitely uh,
definitely changed a lot since you know,
you don't want to get these injections,
you just for no reason.
I just want,
I did it for no reason.
Like,
just like,
fuck it,
we only did it once and I did it twice.
Twice.
Yeah.
But the second time I just felt like I
just left.
I actually went straight from burning
man down there,
um,
and
uh,
I only got 70 and I just,
I dunno,
I,
I did a fast before,
um,
and I kinda like,
I kinda got sick and then I took some
antibiotics.
They say you're not supposed to take
I don't know,
maybe I fucked it up.
I'm not really sure,
but I just remember the first time was a
distinctly like super strong effect.
Yeah.
Well I believe boss route and went to
South America I think.
Do you remember where he said he went?
Jamie Peru.
Did you say Peru?
Yeah,
my buddy doesn't.
Can Cue and I know they were doing it
and determine a.
yeah,
I think just the door if I,
you know,
it's,
it's all,
it's just basically anywhere that is not
the US I think.
Yeah.
Well we got fucked during the Bush
administration when they did these
sweeping ban on stem cells because the
religious right and they went back.
They don't want you to play God and you
know,
it wasn't just that they were concerned.
Stem cells were connected to fetal
tissue and there was this whole idea
that people are going to get abortions
on purpose just to get the fetal tissue
and cell this something.
Yeah,
and they probably would.
I mean someone probably will.
It probably wouldn't be a lot of people,
but it'd be enough that it would be an
issue with some folks,
so because of that,
all these European countries,
especially Germany and got way ahead of
the curve when it comes to stem cell
research and applications in the medical
industry and now what we're seeing now,
you obviously know Regena.
Keem was invented in Germany.
That's how I found out about it for a
knee like fuck.
I think it was 20 years ago or so.
I'm crazy.
I mean,
do you know Mickey Rourke?
I've met him twice.
Tell him to settle down.
Calm down,
dude.
It seemed like it seemed like a good
guy.
Just come down.
He's a whatever you're doing.
Don't do that anymore.
Just just realize what a fucking actor
though the wrath or was it like one of
my favorite movies?
Public Greenwich Village.
Man.
Let me go back to some old shit.
Angel Heart.
So bad motherfucker.
I mean,
it's good.
I just,
the rest of this seems so authentic.
I Dunno.
It's just uh,
yeah,
I just liked that movie.
What was perfect for him at the time
too,
because he was an older guy and you
know,
and he was kind of fucked up.
He let his own the part.
He was perfect for it.
Now,
now he's a fucking amazing actor and
people forget that because he's kind of
a freak now.
But if you go back to his earlier stuff
and you see like how good he was in
diner,
you know what I mean?
He's a fucking.
He was amazing.
But uh,
yeah,
whatever he's doing don't do that
anymore.
But uh,
I know Peyton manning went down there to
Germany and um,
so now let me ask you,
is that,
is that stuff band in professional
sports?
Red Regena keen?
No,
no,
not the.
Not the healing stuff.
I'm talking about.
Just like stem cell infusion.
No,
no,
not yet.
Oh Wow.
But could be soon.
You could
test for that.
I mean,
that's the thing,
what I've been told is you cannot tell
the difference between a regular,
like a stem cell from you or a stem cell
from me or whatever if been scrubbed and
your system.
I mean,
it's like they said to me as stem cells,
the stem cells.
Well,
um,
I paid very close attention to the
latest cutting edge research for doping
[inaudible] the UFC.
And because,
uh,
I'm friends with Jeff Novitsky who was
the guy who busted Lance Armstrong,
who's of course the guy who works for
the UFC now and he and I talk all the
time and it's really fucking interesting
how these people who are trying to get
ahead or like way they're way ahead of
the people that are trying to detect it.
So like now they're developing
testosterone from animals,
which is interesting because you're
seeing people that are taking
testosterone.
It's exoticness testosterone,
but it used to be that they were getting
it from wild yams.
So what they would do is they'd do
carbon isotope tests and they would be
able to detect that the testosterone
inside of your body's not from a
biological.
It's not from an animal that
testosterone is actually coming from a
yam is a Mexican Wild Yam.
It's really interesting.
Um,
but now they're figuring out a way to
extract it from animals at least
theoretically.
So Novitsky Levitsky says it like it
hasn't been proven yet,
but they're pretty sure.
So what they're doing now is they're
taking people's pis and blood and then
they freeze it and they hold onto it for
eight years.
So the idea is that eight years from now
they're going to find out like new
detection methods and they're using
those,
the Olympics now,
which is why two Russian Olympic gold
medalist in wrestling got their metals
taken away from 2008.
Oh yeah.
And they haven't even gone in 2012 yet.
So there's 2000,
12,
2016.
I mean there's,
there's,
these guys are going to get fucked over
for sure.
But you know,
Russia has extensive state sponsored
anti doping agency.
They also are pretty big advocates of.
I mean they were the ones that started
back to.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well they started it.
But also what's interesting is the
scientists that were involved in the
program,
they all got whacked.
They're killing these motherfuckers left
and right.
All the people that know when,
when one guy blew the whistle,
one of the Russian anti-doping guys blew
the whistle and apparently they just
started ice.
And these motherfuckers see if you pull
it up,
Jamie,
like how many Russian anti-doping
scientists have been murdered?
They don't fuck around over there and
they don't fuck around.
And like,
and,
and from what I've heard,
like Putin is like really into sports
too.
So.
Oh yeah,
he's into fighting.
Loves fader fade or million INCO.
Yeah,
whatever happened to that guy
motherfucker time.
Motherfucker.
Time got him,
you know.
And Jesus got them,
got super into Jesus.
Oh really?
Yeah.
He uh,
he changed,
his body changed.
Um,
I dunno,
it's indicative of his training methods.
I've never really had much of a body on.
It's always say Italy.
It's so strange to be when you see guys
like him or especially guys like country
Nelson and this guy,
like I just don't understand how you
could train all the.
It looked like,
like it's like so crazy to me.
Right?
Like I know.
Especially Roy,
right?
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Big country.
He wears it like a bag.
A badge of courage too.
I think Roy,
if he just have really got super
disciplined and lost a ton of way,
he would be fighting at 185 pounds and
you'd be knocking motherfuckers to.
It'd be visible with that fucking chin.
This guys,
big crack.
He's like,
the big guys can't knock them out of the
fucking little guys.
Well unfortunately his chin started to
fail him in recent years.
A couple of in Mark Hunt knocked him
out.
It was just kinda like time.
Right.
But I'm just saying like,
genetically the,
I was blessed with the freakiest Chin of
all time.
Crazy.
Right.
So it's like.
But I just,
I never understood how you could train
that much because,
I mean obviously it's genetics,
but I just remember,
you know,
when I was in the military like going
through and I'll eat like pizza is audi
butter.
I mean I was trying to like gain fat
because it's so fucking cold in this
water.
I couldn't do it.
Granted we were training more hours but
like fuck,
I don't know.
I mean a lot of these,
you know,
UFC guys that I know,
they train six hours a day and it was
just like,
I don't know what Roy eats,
but it's not good.
Whatever it is,
it's most likely a lot of carbs,
most likely he's just taken in a lot of
sugar,
a lot of carbs and his body doesn't know
what to do with it and it just,
he must just have a slow metabolism.
Just,
I don't know.
I mean he certainly trains hard.
He's got endurance.
I mean,
Roy doesn't gas out.
I mean he gets tired like everybody else
does,
but it's not like a fatigue issue.
She didn't know.
What's crazy is.
I knew Roy way back in the day and Roy
was known as being a really good
grappler.
He was a Brazilian Jujitsu competitor.
I knew him before he ever did MMA and
when he did mma,
my thought was,
oh,
well,
you're going to see some high level
grappling from this guy.
This guy's like a stud on the mat.
Nope.
Just started bombing on the ground.
Yeah,
hardly ever.
Well,
the one time we really see his Jujitsu
was in the Andre Arlovski fight when
he's fighting elite ECC,
took our lawsky down.
Hadn't been signed control,
but elite not elite.
ECC was.
They were really corrupt and they had
this weird thing where if you on the
ground from whether 15 seconds it
standing up,
so he's on the ground inside control
with a double double wrist lock going
for memorial on Orlowski and they stand
them up.
Anyone up getting stopped by Orlowski.
But that was.
But that was that.
They were making Kimbo slice their,
their poster boy,
and it was like Gary Shaw was promoting
and he was a boxing guy and he had his
own idea about how to promote it and if
they weren't mma friendly it was just,
they wanted excitement.
They didn't really want to promote like
in a pure sense of the sport,
you know,
so it was a,
the whole thing was kind of fucked.
But I remember I saw Kimbo was down in
Miami and I saw one of his fights or
whatever and they had like some
alternate gallic coming off the couch
and this guidance document.
Wait,
seth petrus,
len seconds.
So that was a bad fight.
They should have never taken that fight.
Seth Petrocelli's very good.
And when I saw that I had known that Kim
Boses a tough guy.
He was a really good guy to
unfortunately he passed away recently.
Just kind of fucked up because he had a
bad heart and he was scheduled for
another fight.
They ever figured out what it was.
It was just had heart disease,
congenital heart defect,
you know?
I mean,
I don't know if it was genetic,
I don't know if it's something that
happened along the way,
I don't know,
but he was a really good guy,
like pretty much universally loved.
Really good guy.
His story is so crazy.
I heard the guy that basically almost
like walked onto the football team.
Yeah.
Yes.
Living on the streets,
like,
yeah,
I mean just a tough,
tough guy knew how to punch and um,
you know what,
when I found out about him,
I found out about them like everybody
else did these youtube videos.
Did you ever see when he fought Sean
Gannon,
Gannon was a cop.
Oh yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
The White Guy,
right?
Yeah.
It's all big white guy.
See if you find that in Sean Gannon
versus Kimbo slice.
They had a Dojo war and he was a cop in
Massachusetts and uh,
he got in trouble for beaten up Kimbo
and like he got suspended I think from
the police force.
Yeah,
there he is right there.
This is a crazy fight,
man.
They just had this one,
this brawl in the middle of this Dojo.
I think Kenny Florian was there and
people were posted.
This was a mixed martial arts.com,
which is the greatest martial arts
website on the Internet.
Uh,
back in the day.
We all watch this shit live.
I don't remember if we had to pay for
it.
It was streaming on some website or
something like that as a of data,
like an aeronautical number.
This I definitely remember being like,
fuck,
this guy could fucking hodges oh yeah.
Well we got tested,
right?
Yeah.
This is what John Gannon is a tough
motherfucker.
I mean tough as hell.
Long time cop real martial artists had a
bunch of pro fights and uh,
there was like all these discrepancies
about the rules because he's got them in
a standing guillotine and they're,
they're trying to break it up and
there's all,
you got to let go and all this different
shit.
So He lets go and then it winds up going
to the ground like there was,
it was all stacked against Gannon.
Yeah.
Because you know,
they didn't want to get submitted and
nobody wants to die.
Right?
Yeah.
And you know,
again has got ahold of this good team,
he doesn't want to let it go and then
Kimbo winds up getting them down on the
ground.
So then kimball's ground and pounded
them see like this,
this is supposed to be illegal to,
you're not supposed to be able to do
this.
But gannon had a fucking head,
like a fire hydrant and it just super
game and great endurance.
And so kimball is used to taking these
guys out and he couldn't take in and out
again and eventually beat him down and
they had some crazy nonsense,
like a 30 count.
Like when he goes down,
you count the 30 before you get back up,
I'm not kidding.
And he beat it once he beat it once.
And then Gannon got him,
knocked him down again.
But like you could see Kimbo starting to
get tired and that was the big thing.
But.
So he goes from this and then starts
fighting in elite ECC and has some great
fights.
Man.
Some really good fights that James
Thompson.
It was kind of controversial as well.
But I knew him as like a pretty tough.
I mean really tough,
but as far as like professional
skillset,
you know,
he wasn't like the elite level
and so when he fought Petros Lee,
I was like,
oh my God,
he's going to get fucked up.
Like this is a terrible fight for him.
Petrocelli's like it's a world class
fighter that happened real quick now.
I remember I was.
Yeah,
it was like front row.
So tell me about your heart attacks if
you can't show me the video.
Yeah.
So basically,
yeah,
I,
uh,
I was,
I think it was 25.
I was on a ski trip.
My fraternity brothers were in Park
City,
Utah Park City and we've just been
partying.
I,
uh,
I met this chick and the lyft line ended
up getting her number and it went to the
bar and I got like everybody shit faced.
It was like 300 bucks,
right?
Cut the whole bar drunk.
We're,
you know,
we're having fun.
We go back to her house or banging until
like seven in the morning or six in the
morning and then I get a call,
like I just showered.
I was like,
just started sleeping on my buddy's
like,
hey,
it's the last fucking day.
Like we're going like,
let's ride.
And I was just like,
ah,
fuck it.
Alright,
sure.
So I took a shot and drink,
have copied,
got my shit on,
went out.
We shot of booze.
Yeah.
Shot of Tequila.
Jesus Christ.
Fuck.
I mean,
you know what I mean if you don't,
if you keep drinking you don't get hung
over.
Right.
So I was just like fuck it.
So when wrote all day and then that
night,
I don't know,
I don't know if it was like a stomach
flu or what,
but I was just like puke in and I just
felt like shit and I just couldn't keep
anything down.
I remember I paid like the hotel guy
like 100 bucks or getting a bunch of
gatorades that couldn't even like leave
my room.
So next day go to the airport.
When I knew that if I got nivea I'd feel
better because I've like had some,
you know,
you know when you get dehydrated that's
usually like the root of most of your
problems.
So I just like ended up buying an ivy
from this medic because the guy's like,
well if I hook this up to you,
you know,
like you're not gonna be able to fly.
And I was like,
dude,
like,
you know,
I gave him a bunch of bullshit.
I was gone,
you know,
fucking medic from the military and you
know,
this and that and I'm,
you know,
qualified to do that.
Anyway,
this guy ended up fucking salary.
The bag basically just gave it to me.
I hooked it up myself,
like on the plane.
And you haven't done this before?
Yeah,
we did it a couple times when we're in
buds,
like if we went out drinking or whatever
and uh,
and we had to train the next day or this
is a commercial flight or a private
flight?
Commercial.
Yeah.
So a pro commercial flight.
You Hook up an IV bag?
Yeah.
Well in the bathroom,
like,
yeah,
before I got on there.
Right.
So I go in the bathroom,
like hooked this thing up,
you know?
Yeah.
You ain't got to wait like an hour.
Right.
So I'm like,
what else we're gonna do is I fucking
hook this thing up.
Start feeling better.
Go to Vegas.
How long did you let it drip in there?
For?
Probably 20 minutes.
I was like,
he just locked the bezirk in the
bathroom and just.
Yeah,
just hooked it up and fucking bang on
the door.
Hey Dude,
I'm going to take a shit.
Nah,
no.
It was like,
no,
I'm pretty sure it was in the airport.
I mean it's just been like fucking 11
slash 12 years.
But yeah,
it was,
I think it was a,
it wasn't uh,
wasn't on the plane.
It was like in the sort of thing and so,
you know,
I just,
and so I sorta sketchy started.
Yeah,
super sketchy.
I don't even know if I use alcohol
and such a scumbag.
So I uh,
yeah.
So I get to Vegas,
I'm like feeling a little bit better.
I'm just like,
I'm such a sick.
I'll want to go gamble.
Right.
Like I should've gone and checked into.
Oh yeah,
I did check into my room.
I should've gone to sleep.
No,
I like go gamble,
play poker all fucking night.
I'm like gambling,
you know,
poker,
stressful and this and that.
My buddy comes to me,
he's like,
Hey,
like,
you know,
we've got these strippers,
like let's go to the Strip club or got
ecstasy and all this drugs.
And I was like,
fuck,
all right,
fine.
You know,
I was like,
winning the poker look fine.
Sure.
So we start getting fucked up,
go to the Strip club and um,
and I asked the,
you know,
and I asked the first check that like
came over,
like,
oh,
like you want them lap dances?
I'm like,
no,
like I haven't slept in like two days.
Like I just want to get a dick sucked,
give you $500 bucks,
right.
Segmenting.
And she's like,
no,
like,
you know,
like I'll fuck you.
And I was like,
no,
like,
you know,
I was like,
I,
you know,
I don't really want to fuck you.
I just want to get the blow job.
And she slaps me like,
because bc she's like offering to fuck
me for free.
And I said No.
So she's like,
oh,
says you slapped me in the face,
right?
I go and I was like,
Damn.
And I was like,
and then this and the next check comes
up and I like offered to the same thing.
I was like,
hey look,
I'll give you 500 bucks or something
ridiculous.
Like I don't really want any lap dances.
She's like,
well,
you know,
I'm down to hang out,
and uh,
and,
you know,
I can get off.
And I'm like,
fuck.
I'm just like,
wow,
this sounds like she's going to want me
to bang her.
I'm like,
I don't want to get slapped again.
I was just so like,
okay,
like,
you know,
get your shit load.
We go,
let's get out of here,
let's go out to party.
So I talked to my buddy,
I'm like,
Hey,
like I need it,
I need a bag or some kind of Dick pill
or something,
you know,
and I'd never taken Viagara.
So I didn't really know the dosing or
whatever.
So he gives me the 100 milligram one,
which is for fucking,
if you don't know anything about Viagra
for like geriatrics,
right business thing.
I take the whole thing.
I don't know,
like a minute goes by and I'm like,
the fucking thing isn't working,
you know,
coked up.
I think it seems like it's been at our
right guys.
Like it hasn't been good enough to give
me the fucking again another pill.
And uh,
so no.
So he said,
he's like,
no,
you can like give me the fucking thing.
So it gives me another user only take
half.
He's like don't,
you know,
don't take this.
And so anyways,
so I'd take another half,
wait like five minutes,
do some more blow.
And I'm like,
oh my Dick's not hard.
Like the girls aren't even around like I
have no,
like sexual esteem is no even reason for
my Dick.
The yard.
Right.
But it's like in my mind I'm like
overthinking it,
which makes it worse,
right?
So I'm like fuck it.
So I take the other half.
So now I'm like 200 milligrams into this
fucking bag or which is like,
you know,
double the absolute Max from what,
uh,
you know,
some guys have to get their Dick
drained,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Well we'll get to that.
So go back to my hotel and I'm like,
fucking banging the shit out of this
girl.
Like,
you know,
I mean I got like veins coming out of my
head.
I'm sweating profusely and I'm like
doing blue.
I'd fucked her for like maybe like 45,
50 minutes.
Like it wasn't not pleasurable at all if
this was like work,
right?
I'm just like.
And after like,
fuck man,
I think it was like 50 minutes.
I just like,
I just quit.
Like I was just like,
I just,
you know,
I just knew there was zero chance of me
coming and I was like,
punished this chick enough and I'm just
like.
And I like didn't like I was tired.
I went in the bathroom,
took a cold shower,
my dick like wouldn't go down like I and
I ordered some room service,
end of like tucking it up into my waist.
And um,
because it's like there's just no going
down for this bucket thing,
right?
It's ether room service I think.
Oh yeah.
Then I actually ended up taking a
volume,
went to sleep banger again,
woke up,
went and ate some Mexican food.
I was like,
betting on the sports game and I started
getting like this pain in my shoulder
and I didn't really like know what it
was like.
It kind of just felt like a,
like an ache.
So started doing pushups that didn't
really make it feel any better.
And I was like stretching my arm and I
was like trying to sleep,
but I couldn't even lay on that side.
I'm just like,
what the fuck?
Like heart attack never even entered
into the realm of possibility of shit
that could be wrong.
Me,
right.
Like fucking 25,
like I said,
like shoulder pain,
like wow,
you know,
I had no idea without having to do a
hard time.
So call my mom tardy at the family
doctor on the phone.
She calls this dude up and I'm like
getting like kind of shorter breaths.
So I'm like fuck.
So I just hang up the phone and I find
out the hospitals like 10 minutes away.
So I'm like,
fuck it.
I'll just get a cap,
be faster.
I should've gotten an ambulance but I
got a cab,
you know,
note to self,
always get an ambulance if you've got
any shit because I got the cab,
I was in the waiting room for like 50
minutes.
I pulled out like 10 grand out of my
pocket.
I told the Lady,
I was like,
I'll give you 10 grand.
Let me talk to the fucking doctor.
Like something's wrong here.
I don't know what's wrong,
but I know something's wrong.
Anyway,
she take the 10 grand,
fuck no.
Made me sit in the fucking waiting room
and like 30,
40 minutes go by.
Finally get seen by doctors like Holy
Shit,
like you're having a full blown heart
attack.
All that stuff and giving the
Nitroglycerin and I call him my dad and
my mom was like,
you know,
telling my mom like I'm thinking I'm
fucking done.
Right.
And because this has been going on for
awhile and I'm like having a hard time
breathing.
I'm like in pain and so they gave me the
nitroglycerin right,
and I,
I start feeling better.
They do an angiogram or whatever where
they check out the heart that said there
was no damage.
Parents come out the next day I have
another one and I'm like,
and I tell the doctor I'm going to say,
and then my doctor was Conrad Murray
too,
by the way,
which is Michael Jackson.
Dr.
Got it.
Smoked him and the craziest.
How's you're talking to.
And the spookiest thing about the whole
deal was my grandfather had the same
doctor in the same motherfucking
hospital exactly one year prior and
died.
So I'm just like,
you know,
this is not looking good for the home
team.
This was before it killed.
Michael Jackson's asked to write sound
like,
you know,
fuck,
I'm just in the hospital.
So I call my dad.
I'm like,
I'm having another heart attack.
I tell the nurse and they're like,
no,
like your thing looks fine.
I call my dad.
I'm like,
there's something wrong.
My Dad like comes down to the hospital
and sure enough like I'm having a
second,
like minor heart attack.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
So they do a bunch of tests to say my
heart's fine and they asked you for like
the list.
So I got to like give him the list.
And my ex girlfriends there,
my mom's there,
my dad's there and I'm just like,
started off with like,
oh well,
you know,
the smoking some pot.
And he's like,
well,
you know,
like,
you better tell us like what you've been
doing.
It's important.
We need to figure out what's going on
with you.
And I say ah,
and you know,
did you know I did some ecstasy cocaine
and like,
my dad like looks over at me like,
what the fuck,
you know,
my dad is like Super Square and um,
anyway,
so then I was like,
yeah.
And I think it took some Viagra.
My girlfriend's like fucking writing now
and he's like,
how much?
I'm like 200 milligrams.
And he's like,
why?
I'm like,
I don't fucking know.
It was good seeing,
you know,
seem like this was tasing.
That's like an insane amount,
like anyway.
So I,
uh,
I ended up staying in the hospital for
like four days.
I actually fucked my girlfriend in the
hospital with all these cords and crazy.
She'll,
Jeez.
Yeah.
I smoked a joint in the hospital thing.
I fucked her,
like I had a buddy of my bringing like
wine coolers and Chinese food,
I think the worst patient of all time.
Right.
And somehow like,
you know,
so give me all these fucking pills.
I got to take their telling me like I
got to take these pills for the rest of
my life for the rest of your life.
So they said,
and I was just like,
after like three days,
like they fucked my girlfriend eight,
the Chinese food.
I was like,
okay.
I'm like back to being invincible again
through all the shit.
He's a heart attack.
Exactly.
I've heard that phrase,
but what is the exact medical thing
that's going on?
You know,
for guidance had to.
I should know.
I don't know.
I think it's just like basically when
your heart's not getting enough oxygen
or something or um,
I dunno.
It's just not functioning properly.
Yeah.
Usually there's like a.
yeah,
there's like a blocked artery.
There's like something and,
and I think like coke is a,
is a vasoconstrictor whatever,
so maybe like constricted my veins.
So there wasn't like an that isn't the
way I grew up.
Visal dilator.
She shouldn't have balance it out I
think,
but I don't know,
you know what I mean?
I don't know.
I don't really know the science behind
it,
but I know that like coke and wag or I
don't think you're supposed to make
some.
I Dunno.
Wow.
I mean,
I know I did a lot of both.
Should've canceled it out,
but I guess it didn't.
I guess my body was like so confused as
going so directions.
It's like fuck you to shut down.
I don't know.
Wow.
But yeah.
That's fucking terrifying.
Twenty five years old and have a heart
attack.
Yeah,
it was pretty crazy.
Right.
But your heart,
your heart obviously works great now.
I mean,
you just,
you did that vegas run crazy bike the
book,
which was a fucking hilarious cause you
and I were talking about it and then
Lance Armstrong gets hold of me.
He says,
hey man,
I don't want to help them.
I remember I got the text view and
you're like,
would you want lance to coach?
I was like,
Oh fuck yeah.
So what did he do?
Shit in the woods.
So I mean he,
it was funny because he came out and I
was expecting,
I was like,
okay,
like you know,
what kind of drugs do I need to do?
I'm like ready to get all doped up and
he didn't really want to talk about it
in the drug shit,
which was kind of disappointing.
He didn't want to talk about the drug
shit.
No,
no.
I was like,
I thought this guy would have like some
like miracle formula.
Right?
I was like ready to get all hooked up,
but I actually had like a super high
humor credit count and he,
he was actually the one that told me,
he's like,
I think sleep apnea makes it so that you
have that you can have a really high red
blood cell count.
So I actually have like the equivalent
of like the guys that are doing the EPO
and doping,
I guess
that helps in some sort of a way.
Well,
because you're,
you're,
you're basically at night you're gasping
for air,
gasping for air,
and you're lacking oxygen.
So it's Kinda like goes back to the
whole like sleeping in an oxygen tent,
right?
So the reason you do that,
it's because you don't have enough
oxygen because you don't your body
stimulate your red blood cell count and
because red blood cells are what
transports the oxygen.
So the less auction you have,
the more your body produces that.
Well if it gets to a certain point,
then your blood kind of turns into
fucking syrup.
Right?
So this is amazing.
Look at that.
A surprising link between sleep apnea
and red blood cell count according to
Sleep Review magazine,
elevated red blood cell count or a high
hematic rate is an indicator of a lack
of oxygen in the person's body.
That's amazing.
So sleep apnea can actually give you
more endurance,
sort of,
you know that the attire,
the.
Yeah,
the problem is you don't really recover.
So I actually got.
I actually because of him actually ended
up getting a mouth garbage I think
helped.
Uh,
I have a really good one and I know,
I know a really good doctor.
I don't know if yours is the same as
what we'll talk about that letting the
mom was like 50 bucks online.
So it's probably not a guide.
It's close to here.
It's,
it actually pushes down on your tongue
because the issue is well with a lot of
guys,
mine was they put my jaw,
like it kind of moved my back jaw
forward a little bit,
Kinda like gives me an underbite.
So I suppose
airway,
but I don't know,
that's not the best one.
Yeah,
there's a better one than that.
For me it's,
it's a life changer.
It changed my fucking life.
You know,
guys will work out a lot in particular.
You developed big neck muscles and that
can constrict the air hole and your
tongue can fall back on that.
Especially if you lie on your back.
Like if I align my back,
dude,
I,
I sound,
it sounds hard,
but it sounds like choking and it's just
terrific.
Yeah,
I'm in the same boat.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
so what did he have you do?
Lance or lance?
Oh,
so I mean I,
I did it,
you know,
I did a good ride with him.
We did like some vehicle drafting,
which was actually surprisingly really
fucking hard because you have to stay
close enough to the vehicle to where
you're like in that draft.
But then if you get caught by a
crosswind and plus if you're,
if you're drafting a vehicle you can't
see like what's in the road and if you
hit any shit in the road,
there's a,
you know,
because on my race I blew out a front
tire doing like 30 something downhill
and almost crashed.
And I was like on the highway doing this
too,
so I like,
you know,
they have those things that wake you up
when you're sleeping,
you know,
there's debate to try hitting that on a
bicycle with little skinny tires you in
like 30 miles an hour.
Like that shit that gnarly.
So it like sent me into the fucking
highway and I'm getting passed.
But like tractor trailers that like 70,
80,
90 miles an hour,
which if you think about it,
if you're in a car and it lays waste
5,000
pounds and it can pull a.
imagine
what it does.
Do a guy on a bike that weighs 200
pounds plus fucking 10 bikes.
We didn't explain the bet what was the
best.
Oh,
so it actually originally were in a
poker game.
And uh,
Scott,
Bill Perkins,
he,
um,
you know,
he just makes crazy best all the time
because he's a real rich guy and he
likes to just fucking make people do
crazy shit.
And it's Kinda like,
you know,
the poker world too.
So the first bet was he bet my brother
that he couldn't go three days without
saying the word,
the,
I think it was like 100,000,
something like that.
And then the,
I think he basically just wanted to shut
my brother up to pay 100 because he was
like,
fuck you.
So uh,
well he ended up buying out because he
realized that my brother was just like
such a stubborn asshole that he wasn't
going to talk for three days and he's
like,
married with kids.
He doesn't have to go out and get any
pussy and like you could probably just
sit home with this fucking miserable
dogs and just like not talk for three
days and just collect a hundred grand.
So you ended up buying out of that.
But that's on the honor system,
right?
I mean all of this honor system.
I mean that's the thing about the poor
communities,
like you lie one fucking time or you
don't pay a debt back and you're just
done.
Like nobody will fuck with you.
So you,
you know,
your word has to be good,
which is kind of like,
you know,
one of my things which,
irritates me,
like when people say that I'm not
authentic because I take great pride and
like,
you know,
being fucking 100 percent honest about
everything,
you know.
So,
and that's been like drilled in through
13,
14 years ago.
Gamble.
That's a big one though if you're
married because you to be like,
listen,
it's me with me.
That doesn't count.
Okay.
You have to save the,
you know,
know that he.
Yeah know he,
my brother Woulda woulda told them.
Um,
and so,
you know,
we're just discussing crazy shit because
in,
in the poker world I've done crazy stuff
like one guy,
but another guy,
5,000
wouldn't jumping the shark tank.
Atlanta's another guy bet that um,
fuck,
what was it?
I mean I bet fuck,
I bet $400,000
on a drag race and I hadn't even raced a
car before.
Um,
and then there was,
there was another,
there's been so many crazy ones.
I'm just trying to think of the
highlight reel a boy.
Um,
there was one really good one,
um,
anyway,
so he and abetting,
um,
I'll think of,
I'll think of some other ones later,
but he ended up betting.
He ended up wanting to Bet Rick Solomon
that he couldn't ride from La to Vegas
or Vegas,
la or whatever on a bicycle in 48 hours
and rick called one of his buddies that
has set some Guinness Book of World
Records Things and asked him and the
guy's like,
look,
like it's not going to fucking happen
buddy,
you can't do this.
And so rick ended up turning down the
bet and it was just really intriguing to
me because I'm always up for physical
tasks,
you know,
like during,
during,
you know,
how you stay up for five and a half days
with no sleep and you run 144 miles like
boats and telephone poles and you get
hypothermia and you're doing all this
crazy shit.
You don't sleep for five days and you're
just
going the entire time.
Right.
So I've like put myself through some
likes and I did two of those.
Right?
So I've put myself through some real
serious,
like physical tests and one of the
things that you learned there is that
your body's just capable of way more
than what you think or anybody else
thinks is capable of doing.
But one other thing that you learn and
gambling is that like there's certain
things that sound like a good bet that
just aren't just like drinking a gallon
of milk in and hour like that sounds
pretty fucking easy.
Right?
But like there's something with the
lactose which like most people just
physically can't do it without puking.
Right.
Because there's just some weird thing.
But like,
who would,
uh,
who would guess that are like saltine
crackers?
Like you can't,
you know what I mean?
Like there's like these weird little
things that like sound super easy but
you just can't do.
Yeah,
I would think a gallon of milk would be
totally doable.
Yeah.
Right.
But it's like,
it's a,
it's like a thing.
I mean,
I remember I like better fraternity
brother and he ended up puking like I,
I bet him before his midterm and I
remember in his midterm,
you know,
vomiting on a girl,
kicked out of his,
like projectile vomited,
like a gallon of milk onto a girl in his
midterm.
I look pretty fucking brutal.
A head.
I was like,
yeah,
we had some funny midterms stories.
I actually ended up taking my vitamins
one morning with A.
I had a thing of Ghb and it looks just
like water,
right?
Oh No.
So I ended up taking like a,
like a full swallow because I had all
these horse pills.
I took like a full swig and I was like,
holy fuck.
I was like,
I knew like as a guide,
but 20,
30 minutes before I turned into a
fucking wild animal.
Right.
And so I just like got in my car and I
drove right down and I called.
My buddy was like,
hey,
I was like,
I gotta take this final.
I'm going to be fucking lights out in 30
minutes.
You got to like,
come pick me up.
But I got to finish as much as I can.
Right.
So I go in there and I got like halfway
through the test and I was just like,
he ended up like carrying me out.
Um,
he was black out,
right?
Yeah.
It was a state called the,
it's a date rape drug.
I think that's real hip.
Normal.
But he used me as well.
They've used that on people too.
Yeah,
you.
Well,
you'd have to be a real fucking asshole
to do that because if you mix it with
alcohol you can kill somebody.
So I know people have done it though.
Yeah.
You got to be pretty hard up for pussy
to like risk killing the girl.
The fucker.
But I don't know.
Have you ever seen.
I'm speaking of the throwing up from
drink a two milk.
Too much milk.
Did you ever see the opiod anthony
sketch with the baby bird?
Did you ever see baby bird know what
that is?
Maybe the most disgusting stuff that
anyone's ever done on the radio.
They had an eggnog drinking contest.
And this dude,
um,
he drank 72 shots of eggnog.
Is that what it was?
Something like that,
but then projectile vomited and then we
were trying to figure out what to do
here before he played this pauses for a
second,
because I'm explain it.
He knew he was gonna throw up.
So they had this intern named Pat Duffy,
this intern's fucking crazy.
And I'm dave from,
from knocky.
No,
who's the other guy?
Pat Pat from when knocky is the guy who
throws up and,
and uh,
Pat Duffy
is the guy who is laying down there and
he,
we were trying to figure out what to do
with the throw up,
like you said,
I'm going to throw up.
And so this guy had done or like,
what was it?
No,
no,
no.
He's an intern.
He's,
he's a fucking animal.
It's.
And one of them are trying to do
anything.
You will fucking do anything for us just
for the store and just for the gag.
So we say,
okay,
here's the idea,
because you know,
I was hosting fear factor at the time.
I go,
here's,
here's the idea.
You lean your head over the edge of the
over the edge of this garbage pail and
he throws up in your mouth and he's
like,
I'll do it.
And we're like,
no fucking way.
And I think bill burroughs one who named
it,
he named it the baby bird.
And so just watch this because the sheer
volume,
you're not even going to believe that
this is really all weekend long.
I'm a caroline's all weekend long.
Here's the plug.
So pat had done this before.
I mean he obviously,
he's a giant dude and he was on like
number,
like 72 and this other kid,
Pat Duffy sitting there with his head
leaning.
He's sitting in a chair leaning back
with his head over this barrel and to
this day,
I mean they've got tarps all over the
ground.
Who else was there fear?
Was there think red band was there to
this day?
Maybe one of the best moments of my life
just because it was so completely
fucking ridiculous.
Yeah.
So here it comes.
He's like,
here we go.
He takes one last chuck and he's like,
I'm going to throw up this.
Oh my God,
you haven't seen nothing.
You haven't seen nothing.
He throws it his face.
Now look at us now.
It keeps going.
This is nothing.
When you think it's over,
it keeps going.
Now Watch.
You think it's silver.
You think it's over like there's no way
he has more and now he's got way more
inside.
If I'm looking at,
Oh my God,
she's actually going to keep watching.
Keep watching.
He's done.
He's not been done.
How's it possible?
Holy Shit.
How is it possible?
Oh my God.
That was like the chicken.
The midterm.
Hang on,
hang on more and this is not fake.
I mean I was there and we were all
there.
We all saw this live
and I think he got his one more inside
of him.
Okay.
He gets one more off now.
He said that's it.
He's done.
Oh my God.
Hold on.
I got to have the greatest fucking
brutal.
Go ahead.
One of the greatest things I've ever
seen in my life.
We're going to get back to this.
A bike racing story.
Ladies and gentlemen in a moment.
Ridiculous.
So it's remembering.
Yeah,
I don't think it was on.
It might've been on one of the jackass
movies or the TV show.
A bams uncle was crazy.
Uncle drank like 70 shots of peach
schnapps.
70 something.
That's right.
Shitload of Bam.
Bam.
Margherita.
With Don Vito.
The big guy.
Yeah.
70 seven projectile vomiting.
All.
I think it was said it was a lot.
It was way more than 20.
I don't know.
You could die from that.
There was a woman in San Jose or
Sacramento,
one of those places where she was doing
a radio contest and it was like,
how much water can you drink?
And she died from drinking water.
Like if you drink too much water,
you could die the disk.
I get sick from this vomit stuff at all
to the kid.
Pat.
No kids.
Bulletproof just doesn't get sick.
That guy ate cat shit.
He brushed his teeth with cat shit.
He also ate fruit loops in the puke.
Like he took a bowl of fruit loops and
mixed it with the puke and ate the fruit
loops.
Yeah.
Um,
there's people out there that are
different than you and I,
Jamie is people that can do things that
we can't do.
What's the why?
Why it's just,
I don't know,
just for the story steps and now I don't
know what we're talking about them
though,
you know what I'm saying?
Like we're talking about,
um,
so it's,
it's one of those things like that's why
he did it.
We're still talking about this isn't a
world pre youtube really,
right.
I don't remember when it was.
It says 2008,
but I don't think that's correct.
I feel like it was earlier than that.
I feel like it was like 2003 or four or
something like that.
I think it was a long time ago is
insane.
Right.
So,
uh,
I think that was like the guy in
college,
so similar to that.
So back to the bed.
So,
um,
so the bed is that you can't ride a bike
from La to vegas,
you have a starting point.
Um.
Oh yeah.
So basically it was two is gonna bet
this guy.
And he like,
looked into it and he's like,
Nah,
that's not possible.
And I was hanging out,
I was just like,
fuck,
I was like doing some research on it and
I like looked it up and I like googled,
like,
you know,
how to prepare for 300 mile bike ride
and a month.
And like nothing came up.
It came up like how to prefer prepare
for 100 mile in like three months.
Right.
So I'm just like,
that's not a good sign.
But I just like,
I don't know,
someone,
Bob and just thought it was possible.
Um,
so like talking to bill is like trying
to get more time.
And I talked to like some buddies that
were cyclist,
like look,
they're like if you had time to train
for this,
like you could do it like,
but there's fucking no way like just off
the couch you could do it.
And I'm like,
how long,
you know,
do I need.
And they're like minimum three months.
So I'm talking to bill and I kinda like
want the bet.
But I'm just like,
I don't know how much money I really
want to risk.
And so he ended up sand that he would
give me because it's because the initial
bet was like,
you just had to go do it tomorrow.
Right.
And I was like,
there's no fucking way,
like,
you know,
and then he's like,
he goes,
well I'll give you a month and I go give
me.
It was like until x date and it was like
a little under six weeks.
I was like,
I'll do it.
And he's like,
how much do you want to bet?
I was like,
ah,
it's like 600 grand because I wanted it
bad enough to where like I would do it,
but I didn't want to bet too much where
it like,
I'd not only like fucking break my ass
but like,
you know,
just lose a shitload.
So I was like $600.
Seemed like it was a good number.
So we made the bat and I started doing
some research.
So I go down to the bike shop and I'm
like,
oh,
like I need a bike.
Like I'm doing a triple century ride and
the guy's like,
oh,
like how,
how much bike?
And I was like,
oh,
like I haven't been on a bike,
like ever really?
I did some mountain biking like 19
years.
The guy just like La.
Yeah,
that response you just like laughed at
me.
I'm like,
no,
like really?
Like I got to do it.
I got like five weeks and he's just
like,
he just like looked at me like I was a
complete fucking retard and I'm like no,
like I've got a bet,
like I'm going to do it.
And then the guy's like,
okay,
like what kind of bike do you.
I'm like,
I don't know,
like you're the bike shop looked like I
didn't have no fucking idea.
Right.
So it gives me like this race bike,
which is super fucking uncomfortable.
So I go out and I ride this thing and I
wrote it like,
I don't know for like 45 minutes and my
ass was just like fucking in so much
pain.
And I'm like,
I am fucked.
Like I think I made it like 11 miles and
I was just like,
this is going to be really brutal.
And so I ended up finding like a bike
where like you could sit down a little
bit more with like a recumbent or
whatever.
It was literally a low rider bicycle.
Right.
Okay.
So that'll kind of alleviate a little
bit of like the ass issue.
And it gave me like a slightly
different,
like pedaling position.
So I got that and then I felt a little
bit better about the bat and then I
talked to like written a little bit but
like nothing over like 20 or 30 miles
and now it's like,
you know,
Kinda like going hard.
And then I talked to you and I talked to
lance and lance like,
Oh,
if you use a fucking any other bike
other than a road bike,
like I'm not fucking,
you know,
I can't have any need to do this.
And I'm like,
why?
I don't know.
Because it's like a purist.
Yes,
he's a bike or out of the fucking no.
So I'm just like,
well listen buddy,
I'm betting big money on this.
I'm like,
I'm going to do whatever the fuck I
gotta do to fucking make it there on a
bicycle.
Right.
And so anyways,
then I Bet Rick Solomon,
Rick,
Rick thought I was going to die because
like the route that I chose was like on
the freeway and I didn't have a police
escort at the time.
So he's like,
you know,
this guy's gonna be driving on the
freeway at night,
like there's going to be trucks pass.
And I'm like he's,
he's got a decent chance of dying.
So.
And he's like in the heart attack thing
now actually went to the hospital
because I was like having some shoulder
pain again.
And it felt very similar to the last
things I was like fuck.
So Rick is like,
you know,
he likes while you were training you
were having shoulder pain?
Yeah,
like after I had done like a long ride.
I'm one of the nights like I,
like I actually went to the hospital,
I was like kind of word.
And so rick was like saying that and I
was like,
well honestly let's bet that I'll bet
you I don't die.
And I was like,
I'll give you a because,
because for me I'm like,
well fuck,
I can't take it with me if I do die,
like fuck it,
you know,
like,
and then it would light up the stakes
for me without really like too much
risk.
And so I was like,
I'll,
I like,
I'll bet you whatever the fuck you want.
You know what I mean?
Like I'll bet you my plane.
And uh,
and I was like,
I'll give you.
I think it was like 10 to one or 21.
I think it was like I gave him like,
fuck,
I think I initially offered them like 20
to one odds and then we settled it.
Like,
I dunno,
it ended up being where he would,
he would lose 250,000
and I would give him like my plane plus
my pilots for he got my plane and then
I'd pay the pilots for a year.
We like at all you die,
you had to die.
But if I didn't,
if I didn't complete the race then it
was like a wash for me.
I'm just like fuck.
It was like Rick didn't think I could do
it,
period.
Right.
So.
So he didn't think there was a
possibility that I could do it.
And then he thought there was a decent
chance that he could,
that I could die.
So for him he thought he was kind of
free rolling.
And for me I was free rolling because
it's like if I die will okay,
I don't need the fucking plane.
Ain't going to take me to hell.
Right.
So like I'm good.
So I made,
I made the bet with him so.
And then I bet a little bit on the side
with somebody else.
I basically had a million bucks on it
when I finally ended up doing it and I.
Yeah.
And I cut a police escort like through
vegas.
So it's so funny because I had like 11
squad cars,
like blocking off all the intersections
and here comes this fucking Dildo on a
bicycle.
Like riding right through it.
I'm like,
have all the,
like,
you know,
you're expecting like a presidential
motorcade to come or like,
you know,
somebody like every,
like looking to see like what bucket 11
squad cars blocking off every
intersection and here's this fucking
asshole on a bicycle.
A lot of people knew that you were going
to do it.
They didn't know when you were going to
do it.
He didn't announce when I didn't want to
announce it because I didn't want people
to fuck with me.
You know what I mean?
Like I didn't want fans to like come out
and,
you know,
or people that hated me or anything,
right?
I just wanted this bad enough as it was,
it'd be on the fucking highway.
So,
um,
I ended up leaving from Vegas and uh,
and I did it in about 32 hours was the
whoa.
And what was the bet?
Uh,
it was,
it was 48.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
So I,
I just remember it because there was
like,
because he was giving me some shit about
cars I was allowed to draft,
but he was saying that the van that I
had had the doors open like,
because you had to leave the doors open
because I want to talk to my coach and
they were like filming it and stuff.
So we had the doors open.
So he was like bitching,
rick was bitching about that,
which was kind of stupid rick to bitch
about because that was like what made it
the least safe of all was drafting off a
car because you got to be like six
inches from this car and you can't see
like shit in the road.
So if they have to slam on the brakes,
you're fucking in the car,
you're crashing.
And we had times when,
like there was a.
yeah,
there was a time when we're on a fucking
one lane road,
right.
And there was um,
there was.
So there's one lane and were in this
lane and there's lane going this way and
we had a car come to pass us as another
car was coming.
And Miss like our van by like inches and
they were doing like 50,
60 miles an hour,
like cross if they were to crash out of
a dead for sure.
Like it was fucking bad.
And so like shit got pretty gnarly.
Some of the spots I blew out a tire
doing like 30 something miles an hour
downhill.
I mean it was like,
who's,
you rest it all while you're doing this?
Yeah,
I slept for like an hour or two,
maybe an hour and a half.
Um,
and then I like stopped to eat but it
was mostly just just truck the whole way
through.
And so you stayed on this recumbent
style bike the whole time?
No,
I did half of it on that and half on a
road bike.
Um,
and then in the second half of it I
didn't,
I just,
I did know drafting,
I just did a road bike with no drafting,
drafting.
He was bitching about it and I just,
I was just like,
fuck it,
I don't need it.
Like it was bitching about,
uh,
while you were riding something like
happens.
Oh yeah,
he was following me.
So I'm having arguments with them and I
was just like,
it was helpful but it only helped on
like flat,
like it.
So it doesn't help at all.
I'm uphill,
right.
So no uphill.
It helps.
And on the downhill I didn't need it
because you're going so fucking fast
that like you don't really want to be
going more than like 30,
40 miles an hour and down hills because
like if you hit shit in the road,
like you're and you crash,
like you're fucked.
You know what I mean?
Like if I crashed,
like I couldn't finish the thing.
So there's that and there's shit in the
road.
I mean I'm almost like the side of a
highway,
there's like tires and nails and you
know what I mean,
like,
so you don't really want to be going
and I couldn't go on the highway because
I couldn't get the police escort for the
actual highway.
The CHP wouldn't do the highway portion
of it.
Um,
so which,
which suck is,
that was like the most dangerous part.
So I was in the breakdown lane instead
of like actually being in one of the
lanes,
so there's just like,
there's just shit and the breakdown
lanes,
you know,
just like fucking nails and whatever.
And you're doing it at night?
Yeah,
there was,
it was like pitch black sometimes we had
high winds.
I mean it was gnarly.
It cut down to like 34 degrees at one
point.
Plus with the winds,
I mean I had a ski jacket on.
What you're thinking to yourself,
what the fuck am I doing?
A.
Yeah,
I mean I've had a lot of those moments
in my life,
but I was more like thinking like I just
didn't know if I could do it.
I just didn't know like physically
because I had just never done any
biking.
I didn't know,
but my legs were just going to like not
be able to go anymore.
I had no real experience in it so I
didn't.
That was my real concern was just like I
knew mentally,
like I was just never going to quit.
I just didn't want to get injured or
like just physically not be capable.
That was like my two concerns.
This is a video of you doing it this,
watch this,
look this,
look at these two cars.
They.
That was.
That was one fucking lane.
They just passed each other.
Yeah.
That was very close.
Thirty eight hours?
No,
30 to 32 hours.
So 48 hours is the bet.
And you did it in 32.
How pissed was when you won?
He actually treated it like a champ.
He didn't really give a shit.
It was pretty great.
It got a lot of money.
He's a baller.
He is for sure.
What does this.
Is this your house or my house?
Just went up on the bike for credit or
are those the grinch?
The next day I was like green.
Fuck.
You said the most one is 51 million.
That was the most you've ever won
before,
but not in one sitting.
That was over a course of eight,
nine months.
And that was just you going at it with
this one dude and you guys playing one
on one when you're doing shit like that.
Oh my God.
I remember there was one point where I
was sitting there,
that's a Granola Bar,
ladies and gentlemen,
you know,
what the fuck is that sound?
And I checked my watch in a while,
so there was one point when at 18
million bucks in front of me and he had
me covered.
So if he said all I had to make a
decision for 18 million bucks,
oh my God,
he's a billionaire.
He didn't give a fuck.
Eighteen dollars million on a hand in
one hand up over.
What's the most you've ever had.
On one hand it was,
I think it was like
14,
10 million,
15 million bucks.
Obviously you had a buildup to this.
Like what?
At any point in time while you're
gambling these ridiculous sums of money.
I mean this is not that long since you
were broke.
I mean this is like you going from
college to you doing this,
you know,
we're only talking about a decade or so.
Yeah.
Um,
that's fucking crazy.
Well,
there was periods of time when been
over.
I've played with like almost my entire
net worth on the day.
Will players do that kind of shit
though?
Stressful.
That's crazy.
I've had my hair fall out before playing
just because you're too freaking out.
Shouldn't stress man,
you know,
like,
I mean there's just so many things that
go into it.
Like you're,
you're,
you're not only thinking about like what
that person has,
but like what do they like?
What did they think that you think that
they have?
Um,
I mean the basic step is what do you
think that they think that you have and
then like the range of hands that they
could have.
Um,
why,
why would he be betting this?
Why would he be calling here?
What type of hands could he have?
Like what are the probabilities that
he's bluffing?
Like what is his mental state?
I mean like trying to pick up on telus.
There's just so many things that go into
it that you're,
you're so focused and it's so much money
and any little mistake that you make is
going to cost you millions of dollars.
So it's like that.
That is like a lot.
And you're playing for sometimes 16,
17 hours.
Like you're just like delirious.
I remember one time while you're
playing,
do you take like provigil or add
adderall or anything?
I took adderall and it really fucked me
up because I just like try to win every
hand and it may be too aggressive and I
just fucking plane crash into the
mountain.
It was terrible.
So try that a couple times.
No good.
Um,
try weed and it fucking was terrible
every time I was bluffing a little
paranoid so I,
you know,
know.
And then sometimes I've taken like
volume just so fucking relax,
you know,
because I'm just like strung out.
But then that makes you kind of not give
a fuck and so you do stupid shit.
It's.
Yeah,
you just almost got to be sober.
What about Beta blockers?
Um,
I never tried them.
I never tried to meet her,
but I saw this thing on concert
performers,
like a penis or it was actually some
people that playing in an orchestra.
They were talking about,
they took Beta blockers and it made a
massive impact because they were super
nervous about performing.
And I always thought about it.
I was like,
man,
that's a,
I guess it just stops you from getting
nervous.
I would be really curious to see what
that feels like.
Yeah.
No,
that'd be interesting.
I,
uh,
yeah,
I've definitely heard of that.
I think uh,
I think it's a big thing for actors and
stuff like that with stage fright or
whatever.
Sure.
At just don't know how long it lasts
because like I said,
I mean these are,
you know,
you're talking about 18 hours sessions
and it's just like.
And also you don't want anything to fuck
with your,
like mental acuity.
Yeah.
Um,
so
game.
Do you lead your study strategy and
read,
read poker books?
And
I did,
I did back in the day,
but back in the day it wasn't quite as
advanced.
Now they have so much stuff online where
you can basically watch these pros play.
And I'll give you an example.
Back when I was playing,
um,
I would play in college.
I played 10 tables at a time.
And you,
yeah,
and you would see about 100 hands an
hour.
Um,
and let's say I just played for a 10
hour session.
So you're playing 10 tables
simultaneously.
How do you do that?
You have like 10 windows open up.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yes.
You're going click,
click,
click.
All between all of them.
Many of sometimes you have multiple
monitors set up.
Um,
and so basically in that period,
if you extrapolate that out,
that's,
you know,
you're seeing 10,000
hands right in that 10 hours of sessions
because 100 hands an hour per table
times 10 times 10 times 100.
Um,
so if you plan a casino,
you're seeing about 20 hands an hour and
you're obviously only playing one table.
So that translates to 200 hands for that
day.
So have one one day playing online,
I've seen 10,000
hands,
one plant,
one day playing live have seen 200.
So you can imagine one day playing
online,
I've seen more hands than a guy that's
played in a casino for his entire life.
So just think about those numbers.
And so the thing is like when you're
playing in casino.
Yeah,
exactly.
This picture,
who's that dude?
Lke,
what's his name?
Lke Elk.
Why?
That's his whole name.
Was He like Oprah?
I don't know.
He's,
I think he's a Swedish guy or something
like that.
And so he's just,
he's got four giant monitors going on
that like.
I mean these guys are say more tables.
That guy's got 12 on each side.
Yeah.
Wow.
So I mean this is what it's evolved to.
You know,
I was like one of the pioneers of this
stuff because this guy got a fucking six
monitors here.
So when,
when you,
you can't do this in America anymore?
Correct.
Like it used to gamble online.
It's stopped.
I think a black pride or was in 2009.
Was it?
Fuck too.
Why not?
I mean,
why not?
Why can't my kids total bullshit?
I mean it's a game of skill.
Clearly.
I mean they allow the fantasy because
it's a game of skill.
Um,
and yeah,
I just,
I think it's nonsense.
I don't really care because I wouldn't
be playing online anymore because I
can't compete with these kids.
They've just put too much time in it.
And the thing is now there's so much
software that does so much for them.
Like for instance,
it'll tell you how many hands each
person plays preflop,
how many,
what percentage of the time they bet the
flop,
what percentage of the time they
bluffed,
and they can just figure that out based
on like how often they're going to have
a hand in how often they bluff.
So to actually give you their bluff
percentages on each street,
on the flop,
turn the river and it'll tell you like
how,
how many times they're just like calling
bad.
Like it'll just give you all these
stats.
So it's almost more turned into like a
mathematical computer game.
Whereas I liked the more pure form of
just like I'm looking the guy in the
fucking.
I'm just trying to figure out what he's
got.
And you know,
you're.
And you're also playing the player.
Like when you're playing live,
like you know,
for me,
I can calculate how much money a guy has
very fast.
I can figure out like his comfort level
with bluffing.
I can figure out the type of guy he is.
Whether or not he's aggressive,
whether or not he's the type of guy that
when he's winning,
he's gonna want to lock it up or the
type of guy that when he's winning,
he's want to gamble more.
The type of guy that when he's losing is
going to kind of play a lot more hands
and try and get even,
or the type of guy that going to just
try and wait for a big hand.
The type of guy that's going to be just
calling his money,
chasing,
trying to get lucky.
That kind of got,
that's going to be pushing the action
and betting a lot.
Like there's just so many things that go
into it that,
you know,
I like to just,
play live.
And I like talk to people and I liked
it.
You know,
have that human interaction.
There's a lot of these guys that are
really good behind a computer,
but you put them in front of another
guy.
You can't look at man in the eye and
just fucking blow up.
You'd just like crumble,
you know,
so,
so online.
They can click that button and say all
in and do these crazy bluffs,
but you know,
they just physically can't push those
chips in and keep a straight face on a
table.
So you know,
there's something going on when you're,
when you're looking at them,
there's like,
there's a certain amount of weeks.
I,
like I said,
I've never played poker.
So there,
there is a certain amount of intuition
and instinct.
Yeah.
Uh,
it definitely is.
It's not like in the movies where it's
like,
oh,
like I picked up a tail on this guy and
every time he bluffs he twitches or you
know what I mean?
Like,
like that's a rare thing.
It's more,
it's more just like understanding the
person.
It's like you figure out what kind of
job this guy does,
like how much money he makes a year.
Like how much this money means to them,
how much he cares about the money,
how much he wants to gamble,
how much he's playing for fun,
how much he wants to win.
Some of these guys,
they just,
they actually want to lose their,
just like self sabotagers,
you know,
they'll go in there and like some of
them I'll see them and they'll want to
lose because they'll want everybody at
the table like them.
And that's kind of like,
you know,
the path of least resistance.
How do you detect that?
Like how do you detect that a guy wants
to lose,
he'll be,
you know,
he'll be just like wanting to be friends
with everybody and he'll do shit to show
off or to like,
you know,
make.
Because I mean look at the end of the
day,
like people want people to play bad,
right?
Like you want a player to play like shit
you want to play or to give his money
away.
You want to play or to,
you know,
uh,
do crazy stuff.
So these guys will know.
They'll put on a show for people that
want to be the popular guy.
Maybe they weren't cool in high school.
Maybe they want people like them who
knows what their reason is.
Maybe they feel like they don't deserve
the money.
I'll play with a lot of guys that,
you know,
some of them ended up in jail,
some of them are fraud somewhere cheat.
Some of these guys,
you know,
they have a bunch of money and they feel
like they don't deserve it
subconsciously,
so they'll just want to give it away.
It's just the thing that's interesting.
And do you see a lot of guys who just
lose everything?
I've seen it before.
Yeah.
I've seen guys go completely broke.
It's tough because in gambling you can
just keep going up but you can't really
go down.
It's like for instance,
if you go and you play blackjack and you
bet whatever arbitrary number of $500 a
hand.
Right?
And you were playing 500 bucks at hand
and you know,
your level of excitement when you win is
at a seven and you keep playing and
whatever and then now you go and play a
thousand bucks a hand and even winning a
little bit or you've been losing or
whatever.
And now if you try and go back to $500
to 50,
it's just like,
you know,
if you're losing,
it's just like it's,
it's a mental fuck because it's really
hard to get even betting smaller and if
you've been winning you don't really
care about the small money.
Right.
Like you want to,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like one of those things where like
once you go up it's really hard to go
the other direction.
So a lot of,
a lot of the problems that professional
poker players have,
it's called bankroll management,
where they keep going up and up and up.
And then when they start losing they,
they are completely unable to drop down
and steaks and then play good.
You know,
like if they lost let's say $100,000
just to use round numbers at,
you know,
this game.
Then for them to go to play a game
that's half that size and try and win
that hundred $100,000
back,
it's going to take them twice as much
time.
You know what I mean?
So it's kind of like one of those things
where,
you know,
in the games have gotten bigger and
bigger and bigger,
so somebody goes on a bad run,
like,
and poker is their profession.
It's not like,
you know,
that's,
that's another thing that people don't
understand.
It's like,
you know,
people,
people are like,
oh,
you're winning.
Like you should,
you should take the money and run.
It's like,
no,
like when you play poker for a living,
like it never ends.
Like there it's like yeah,
there may be session to session but like
you're always going to be playing poker.
So it's like if that's a good spot you
should just play until the game's over.
Like even if you want,
it's not like blackjack where you should
just lock up a when like in poker you
just stay there and in fact the more
you're winning,
the more other people are losing and the
more other people are losing the worst
they're going to play.
So it's Kinda like one of those things
where you just,
you know,
it's just one long session.
It never ends.
You know
how pissed too people get when they lose
fuck tons of money.
If you ever had issues with that where
people get violent or people were angry.
Definitely angry.
And it's funny because,
and I,
and I'm a victim of this too,
like I've found sometimes I've gotten
far more angry at losing $20,000.
Then I have at losing $500,000.
A strange as that may sound.
I'm just because
you know,
of the way I lost it or if I played
shitty or if I lost it to a guide in
like,
or it was just like I lost,
lost,
and just like a steady progression of
losses.
Or if I was up a ton of money and then
like let's say I was up a million
dollars and ended up losing $20,000.
Like I'd be fucking miserable even
though I only lost 20 grand.
But let's say I was down a million
dollars and I ended up losing $20,000.
I'd be ecstatic.
Now look at the end result was one night
I,
I
one slash 20 grand and I was miserable
and the other night I lost 20 grand and
I was happy,
right?
Because I started off up a million and
then last ended up being a $20,000
winner.
Like that seems like a million dollar
loss to me because at one point in that
game I was up a million bucks,
right?
So mentally,
you know,
I kinda like in my mind I've lost a
million dollars.
And then in the other game I was down a
million and then ended up only losing
$20,000,
so almost broke even.
So I'm like ecstatic,
you know what I'm saying?
So there's
also something that you were just
talking about that I think is really
interesting because it kind of parallels
a martial arts and fighting and a lot of
ways is that you don't want to lose
someone that you hate.
Yup.
Yeah.
And that's a big factor.
And fighting.
That's why conor mcgregor does so well
is that he fucks with your head so bad
that the amount of pressure that's on
you is so exacerbated when you actually
get into the cage with them.
Like even guys like Josie,
although who's this seasoned world
champion who never lost in the UFC,
hey connor just mind fucked him and he
can punch.
I mean it's,
it's both things.
He's got skill and he's really good at
handling pressure and he's the mindfuck
master,
but you see it with guys when guys get
in these emotional situations with
fighters and then you see when they
fight with someone who respects them and
shake hands the weigh ins and they could
fight up to their full potential.
I that that is a big factor I guess in
poker as well.
Yeah,
definitely.
I mean there's,
I've seen tons of times when somebody
really hates another player and in fact
like has just played far worse against
that guy and given that guy so much
money because they,
they,
they kept going after him.
You know,
like they really wanted bluff them.
They're like,
fuck this motherfucker.
I'm not going to let this guy blocked me
and then they ended up just paying them
off and paying them off and paying them
off.
I actually found that in poker because
there was times when I'd be friend,
really bad players and then that player
would not play hard against me,
you know,
because of that.
And it actually ended up costing me a
bunch of money and then there's other
times when I would just like talk shit
to a bad player and they would really
come after me and then I'm just smoking
them,
you know?
So it's Kinda like,
it's tough because usually the bad
players were the coolest guys because
they're just like the rich guys that are
having fun and they got a good attitude
and this and that.
But sometimes you know,
like you gotta fuck with them a little
bit,
you know,
cause otherwise you're not going to be
able to gamble with them really.
You know.
So you want that.
Like you want that kind of like,
optimally you want that competitive but
semi friendly relationship because you
don't want them to just totally hate you
because then you'd be like,
fuck this motherfucker,
I'm not playing if he's there and then
you're kinda like out of the game
because he's the big sucker and he can
call the shots,
which just seems like such a
psychological management thing with,
with poker players.
There's a lot,
man.
It's a real,
it seems on the surface like an easy
thing to do.
No it doesn't.
But I feel like for a lot of people they
look at it and they're just like,
oh,
he gambles for a living.
Like he got lucky or he's just like good
with numbers.
You know?
They've break it down so simplistically
that they don't realize like how
difficult it is.
But isn't that the case with everything?
I mean I've heard people say that about
Nascar,
like Oh,
they'll just turn left.
Like No.
Well Nascar's,
I would,
I would come.
I think that the closest comparison is
with the stock bark,
like stockbrokers,
stock market stuff,
you know,
because they're really gambling.
I mean at the end of the day that that
is kind of gambling and you know,
and they're going to have losses.
The,
the,
the parallel there is that you can go
into work,
you can fucking do a good job,
bust your ass to everything,
right,
and then just get fucked because of bad
luck.
That can happen to a doctor.
Really.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that can't happen with most
professions.
Like even in fighting,
like even the loser gets paid,
right?
You don't go into a fight and lose money
if you lose,
right?
Like poker and the stock market or some
of the few things that like,
it's kind of hard to really have that
good bankroll management because you can
go into everything,
right?
Bust your ass and work for an entire
month and lose money.
But that is where the thrill lies to the
common man,
the,
the average person that plays it safe
and takes it easy and gets his 401k and
doesn't,
doesn't do anything risky.
That's where the thrill lies and that
lifestyle,
like talking to you and hearing you talk
about this shit,
that's where people that are getting
their palms are sweaty right now when
they're driving to work and they listen
to this and thinking,
could I do that?
Could I do that?
Most people can't.
Most people cannot.
It's,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's one of the hardest things I've done
and I've done a lot of hard things just
because for me doing,
doing physically hard things actually
isn't like as challenging as mentally
tough things.
Um,
if that makes any sense because the
physical stuff fit the physically tough
stuff.
You just kind of like sparking bite your
tongue and grit and fucking take the
pain and just power through like,
well that's got to be one of the
benefits of going through buds twice.
Yeah,
I mean it puts it in perspective.
Yeah.
I mean just,
you know,
you've been through way more of a
hellacious physical test than most
people could ever endure.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think a lot of it comes down to,
you know,
a lot of people are like,
oh,
like,
you know,
you must be a super tough motherfucker
and all this other shit.
And I think it comes down more to just
like how bad you want it.
Like in life,
like if you just want something so
fucking bad.
Like I just remembered like when I was
doing the 50 meter underwater swim is
really hard for me.
I'd never been able to do it.
Um,
outside of,
you know,
seal training and the only two times I
did it was when I had to do it and I
just remembered,
I was just like,
well I'm just going to swim until I
fucking reached the wall or blackout.
Like there just wasn't another option.
Like I was just like,
I just wasn't going to quit just because
I wanted it so bad.
So that actually helps you.
I remember there's one guy that that
went into buds and he was um,
he had like a million dollar business.
I think it was,
I think it was the guy that owned van
Dutch or something maybe,
or had some affiliation with that and I
just remember he went into buds after
that.
I just remember he showed up and he had
like a hot chick or two hot chicks and
it,
a sports car and everybody's like,
fuck,
he's a stud.
You know what I mean?
Like it was like,
and then he like showed up a buds and
ended up quitting like straight away.
And I was just like,
but it didn't surprise me because I'm
like thinking,
you know,
if,
if I don't make it I'm going to ship and
I'm going to be fucking miserable.
Like I don't want that.
Like this guy's thinking like if I quit
I can go like fuck a bunch of girls and
like drive nice cars.
And I got money.
Like,
you know what I'm saying?
So like for him it was like,
I actually think it's harder,
you know,
like,
because you look at like,
you know what your alternatives are,
you know,
like,
if you,
if you put a fucking guy up against the
wall and he's got no choice,
then he's just going to like do what
he's gotta do.
Like for instance if I told you you had
to go crawl,
you know,
50 miles or I'm going to fucking put a
bullet in your head,
like you're probably going to go crawl
that 50 miles.
But,
but I told you,
hey,
like I'm going to give you $500,000,
you know,
if you can go crawl these 50 miles,
but you know,
you got money and you don't really need
it,
you're probably not going to crawl 50
miles.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it's Kinda like one of those
things.
It's just like the alternative is what
determines the difficulty.
It was a great scene and officer and a
gentleman remember what your gear.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I remember that.
I do remember that.
And that's exactly it.
I got nowhere else to go.
That's one thing I tell people when
they're thinking about fighting,
I say,
is it all you want to do?
Is it.
Is it your whole life?
Does it absorb you?
Does it do?
Do you want that more than anything that
you can imagine?
It's not like,
well,
fighting doesn't work out.
I'm going to be an author it because if
that's the case and you want to do it
for the experience,
that's cool,
but if you actually think you're going
to be a champion,
if you have all these other escape
routes and it's
not going to happen.
That's why I actually think it's harder
for guys like conor mcgregor or guys
like mayweather because now they have
money and they have that lifestyle and
it's like that.
I actually thought Rhonda was going to
get fucked up just because she likes
she,
you know,
she was going to Hollywood.
I mean,
don't get me wrong,
she's tough,
she's fucking great,
whatever,
but you know,
she was like doing the movies and she's
doing this and it's like I just,
I know that lifestyle and I know the
addictiveness of the money and the fame
and all that other stuff and now it's
like these people that have been
fucking,
you know,
living in a one bedroom apartment are
now introduced to all this money and all
this fame and people and it's just,
it's so distracting as opposed to the
guy that's like,
you know,
fucking waking up everyday and going to
the gym and fucking busting his ass and
just trying to make ends meet and that's
all he's got and he's got no fucking
nowhere else to go.
Like you said,
you know.
And,
and for that guy,
I feel like it's far easier to stay the
course for garlic,
conor mcgregor.
Now he's got all this money and this and
that,
you know,
he's,
he doesn't have to fight anymore.
Like like I mean,
yeah,
he like if he wants to continue his
lifestyle,
he does right now he's like up as
expenses in his image and all this stuff
and he's used to all this stuff and now
he has to make x to maintain his current
situation.
So he's got a little bit of pressure on
them in that sense,
but he's not,
he's not struggling.
He's not hungry anymore.
You know what I mean?
He's got the pencil on who you are
though.
I mean everybody has a different
motivation.
Some people,
it's not even like they changed the
goalposts instead of becoming rich.
It's become the greatest of all time.
It's like you look at all these other
guys that are nipping at your heels and
you decide,
no motherfuckers,
I am the man at the top of the mountain
and I'm going to stay at the top of the
mountain as long as my body hangs in
there.
But again,
it's like that has to be something that
you want to do and you could see the
shift.
I see the shift in guys were,
they all of a sudden they do it for
money and they started doing it for a
living.
You see that shift and it's an ugly
shift because they just don't have the
same tenacity is like I see a lot and
like nfl and stuff like that,
I'm sure we get tired of getting your
fucking bell rang to men know he get
tired of Bang Bang clashing heads with
people and running into each other.
After a while that shit gets tired.
I remember there was a big basketball
player,
um,
and he would play poker and it was funny
because he would go on these vendors and
he would play for like 24 hours straight
or something.
I just remember we just always bet
against him and he was like a big,
big basketball player.
Like he was like the star on the team or
whatever.
And so we were just like,
always bet against like whatever team he
was playing,
if he had been playing poker for 24,
48 hours,
which is bet against the other team were
right,
like almost every time.
Like he just like always played like
shit.
Yeah,
fuck yeah.
It's like mentally exhausting.
He's not sleeping,
you don't eat.
It's just like it's just hard on your
body or you,
you're screwed.
The cortisone or whatever cortisol
levels go up.
I mean it's just like,
yeah,
it's,
it's tough.
I mean it's a balancing act I think in
anything in life,
but especially in risky things,
whether it's playing poker or fighting
or anything along those lines.
Something that's really difficult to do.
There's this weird balancing act and you
have to this this perfect balance of
motivation,
reward,
intensity,
focused,
disciplined,
but still pleasure.
You can't be miserable forever.
Like there's to be a time where you have
fun too.
It's hard.
I mean,
like I said,
I think it just comes down to like,
you just gotTa want it,
you know,
you just got to fucking just want it
really bad.
But there was some study recently that I
was reading about whether they were
talking about how you can't be happy all
the time and you don't want to be happy
all the time.
Like literally,
you won't achieve the same levels of
happiness all the time if you're not
miserable like you,
you don't ever hit those highs unless
you hit those lows like you ever been
around someone who's manic ever day to
check his manic.
I know where you're talking about the
suite is a sweet,
the
bitter end.
And I've found that I'm actually have an
interesting outlook on that because I
have bought pleasure for so long,
I can't buy happiness.
You can buy a pleasure though.
And a lot of people say,
oh,
money isn't happiness,
money can buy a boat and the boat will
make me fucking happy.
That kind of thing.
Right?
So I'm an example I like to give is,
you know,
when I was 16,
like my dream car was a,
um,
a Mustang Cobra,
right?
So if I got a Mustang Cobra,
I would have been a 10,
right?
Um,
but,
you know,
a Ferrari would also bring me to a 10.
I mean,
he,
but you can't go higher than a 10,
right?
So let's just say that I got,
um,
you know,
uh,
the,
when I was 16 and now we flash forward,
I graduated college and my dad gives me
a,
let's say he gives me a BMW m five,
if I had the Ferrari,
now I'm going to be kind of like
probably at a seven,
right?
Because I'm stepping down on a car.
But if I had the Mustang Cobra and now
I'm going to an m five,
I'm going to be back at a 10.
Well it's the same car.
You're the same person.
You're at the same spot in life.
The only difference is your perspective
because your previous experience,
you know,
so it's Kinda like when people ask like
why rich people aren't as happy and I
just think it's because they've upped
the bar so far that only the best things
satisfy them.
Like a guy off the street.
If I took like when I was going to the
bootcamp,
I'll use that as an example.
I go to outback steakhouse,
I'm going to 10 right now.
If I go to the best restaurant in the
fucking world.
I mean,
I'm like maybe like a six or a seven.
I'm just like,
satisfied.
I got three chefs,
like I eat the best food all the time,
you know what I mean?
So like that doesn't make me happy
anymore.
Like if,
if somebody bought me a Lamborghini,
I'd be like whatever,
like I've had them,
I don't care like it.
But if you're gay,
you know,
give it a guy off the street,
he'd be at a 10 so I can't buy happiness
anymore.
You know what I mean?
I bought every fucking thing that I ever
wanted,
right.
There's not really anything that I want
so I can't buy any like,
pleasure.
Um,
and also if you gave me like a regular
car or put me in a regular hotel,
I would actually be it like below the
normal level.
Whereas a normal person would be like
happy to be on a vacation,
you know what I'm saying?
So like I think that has like some
correlation.
It's Kinda
like a guy that wins the lotto like a
year later.
He is like statistically less happy than
a guy that got his leg amputated a year
prior,
you know?
Yes.
That's,
that's interesting.
It's also,
I think,
what are you trying to do?
Like do a lot of people that are trying
to get rich because they think that once
they get rich there'll be happy.
They think that that's going to give
them this thing that they've always been
missing.
And so they've been working hard,
busting their ass and they look at all
these other people like we're talking
about,
you know,
you uh,
you land your private jet,
you drive your,
your Bentley to the club.
And everybody's like,
oh,
samples,
you want to be that guy.
Right?
But once you're that guy,
it's like,
that doesn't mean anything anymore.
And then for a lot of people there's
this emptiness,
there's nothing left to chase,
there's nothing else to do.
And your life is just about possessions
and upping the ante.
And now I got to get a yacht and now I
have to get the biggest yacht.
Now I've got to buy an island,
you know,
and trying to find something to fill
that void.
Because you've sort of set your life up
to chase these material goals instead of
to try to find out what actually does
make you happy.
You have to have goals and you have to
have stuff that like,
you know,
you got to be climbing the mountain
because at the end of the day like
climbing the mountain is far more
satisfying than being at the top of the
mountain.
You know?
Isn't that weird though?
That's not what we've ever been taught.
Well,
it's counterintuitive because most
people don't like get the,
they just know that like,
okay,
like,
you know,
my dad told me like it's better to give
than receive.
And I was like okay,
that's perfect by the burglary unit,
just give me shit and I'll receive it
and I'll be happy.
Like,
you know what I'm saying?
but you don't have it.
If you don't have it then that makes
sense.
Yeah,
exactly.
And like,
you know,
just people.
I mean it's just experience like,
I mean like from the time you're a
little kid,
you get something,
you're happy.
Like you know,
you get a boat,
you're happy.
Like if I have this bike,
I'm be happy and,
and it's true and it works,
you know what I mean?
But there's a point you almost have to
like get really rich to understand that
you really have to just buy all that
shit.
It was okay.
Like I got it all,
it's cool.
That made me happy,
but it's temporary,
you know?
That's,
that's I,
that's kind of where I differentiate the
happiness and the pleasure,
you know,
you can buy the pleasure for the
pleasure is somewhat short lived,
you know?
Yeah.
I had a conversation with someone about
this recently where I was saying that
material possessions,
once you have enough money to acquire
basically everything you want,
they don't mean anything anymore.
So they don't mean anything.
You can enjoy them when you have them.
What if you lose them?
It's really not that big a deal.
You know,
if like if you get an escalate and
fucking meteor hits,
you're escalating and go out there.
Homes get another escalate,
there's bunch of them.
It's no big deal.
But if that was all you had and you had
a save and scrape up your money to get
that escalate and he kept it clean,
then it got hit by a meteor.
You'd be devastated.
Yeah.
Once you have achieved this level of
success where material possessions don't
mean anything anymore,
then you can kind of like,
okay,
well what do I enjoy?
Camaraderie,
friendship,
creativity.
Like what is it that I'm actually
chasing?
Because I remember talking to this
Buddhist monk,
I had to do this thing once where I went
to all these different religions.
It was for this TV show and I
interviewed all these different people
and ask them like,
what?
You know,
what is it about your religion that's
the best.
Like say if I was going to join your
religion,
you try to sell me your salad,
and the Buddhist guy was saying that sex
and all these material possessions,
they,
they possess you and that to be
completely free,
you have to be abstinent and you have to
be free of material possessions.
I said,
well,
why?
I go,
what if you achieve a level of success
where you don't worry about those things
anymore and they don't,
they don't,
they don't contain you,
they don't hold you there,
you're not a prisoner of them because
you're really not worried about them.
Like if all you had was this one thing
and that one thing was taken from you,
that would be devastating and that's
what this is based on.
But what if you had unlimited resources?
If you were,
if you were Richard Branson or someone
like you or whatever,
when you're,
it's not an issue then then those
material possessions no longer possess
you,
but this guy didn't want to look at it
that way.
Like he didn't want to think that that
was ever a possibly an option.
I'm like,
well,
it's not an option because you don't
think it's possible to achieve that
level of material possession of that
material success.
Yeah.
And that's Kinda the thing I feel like
you have to,
you have to get to that place to
understand it.
You know,
it's Kinda like tell him that
to anybody who's listening to this like
99 point nine percent of people
listening to this are never going to
make a fraction of the amount of money
that you've earned.
Yeah.
But you know,
in some ways that is a blessing because
they're going to have a lifetime of
being able to buy that pleasure to
because of that.
You know,
because if you start here on this lower
rung than all those little purchases and
stuff like that,
you're still like,
you're enjoying the shit out there.
Their baseline is just lower,
right?
They get a new fishing rod,
they're fucking pumped.
Exactly.
You know,
and when that wears off,
then they're gonna get a new reel and
you know,
when that wears off,
they're gonna buy a new depth finder.
What,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like it's the little ship,
that little shit.
If it makes them happy,
then that's,
then that's okay.
But,
but to the people listening to this
right now,
they're thinking,
okay,
well you're equating material
possessions in the acquisition of these
material possessions as being the thing
that makes people happy.
Now is this because you've got 15
bitches and you're flying around on
private jets and yachts and you're,
you're lacking like real depth to you.
You're a smart guy.
You're not a dumb guy.
So I don't,
I don't think that that's the case.
I think you're having a lot of fun and
you're,
you know,
you're doing a lot of wild,
crazy shit.
But I don't think you're lacking in
depth.
Yeah,
no I am just trying to fully experience
everything that I wanted to experience.
And there also a part of me that's,
you know,
Kinda doing some wish fulfillment,
some part of me that's overcompensating
for lack of things,
you know,
that I had childhood was or when I was
growing up or that I wanted or whatever
it was basically just kinda like
whatever I wanted when I was younger or
whatever I place emphasis on,
I kinda like just overexaggerated and
beat it into the fucking dirt.
So then now I can move on and do
something else like my life,
you know,
I have,
I have add,
so for,
it's like hypersensitive or real.
I think it is and I think I think a lot
of successful people have it and I think
what it allows you to do is when you are
focused on something and when you have
that like pinpoint focus,
you can be extremely successful but when
you don't,
you're just scattered all over the
fucking map and you can't accomplish
anything.
I mean you're just like.
And I think a lot of kids have nowadays
because of the stimulus,
I think.
I think you have so much stimulus at
your fingertips nowadays that these
kids,
if they're not,
I guess I guess what I'm trying to say
is that people just overstimulated in
and because they have it at their
fingertips all the time.
Like when I was a kid,
like we used to have to entertain
ourselves.
You said it was just like go out and
play,
you know,
and just like figure out shit to do.
And so we didn't need massive amounts of
stimulus nowadays.
If kids don't have a fucking video game
and a movie playing at the same time,
they're bored and three other friends to
talk to,
you know,
so it's when they're hanging out and
they're constantly checking their phone,
they're not even looking at each other.
They know.
Yeah.
And I'm victim of it too,
you know,
it's like,
it's crazy you'll,
you'll be,
you'll be in a social setting and
there'll be five,
six people at a table and they'll all be
on their phones and it's just like,
it's Kinda sad that,
that we've been reduced to that level of
interaction where it's just like
electronic,
like this just all electronic and
people,
you know,
like I mean when people call people
nowadays,
this is like,
wait,
what the fuck?
Like why are you calling me back when we
were kids,
like there wasn't even texting,
you know,
it was like flip phones.
Like now it's like if somebody calls
you,
it's like,
wait,
what the fuck?
I go,
I have one friend,
Joey Diaz.
We never text each other ever.
He might've texted me once,
I was like,
what the fuck is going on?
All we do is call.
He goes,
I don't like to text.
I like the car,
I want to hear your voice.
I'm insecure.
I want to know you love me.
Like you.
He wants to talk to you on the phone.
I think that's,
yeah,
we're,
we're definitely missing something.
We definitely missing something by all
this electronic shit,
but it's,
it's also like a new style of living and
I'm sure humans will adjust eventually.
We'll figure it out how to manage it or,
or change accordingly.
The one positive thing I think is just
that you,
you're so connected,
you know,
everybody.
I feel like everybody's more connected
now.
Like back when we were kids,
like you know,
a guy in Idaho is never going to fucking
feel any connection whatsoever with
somebody that's in California,
but now like that guy can upload a
youtube video and everybody around the
world can see it and people are just,
you know,
dating wise,
social media wise,
like whatever.
They're just,
there is more connection.
I mean I feel like it's,
it's not quite as real and it's not as
tangible but.
And people I think are also losing,
I'm losing the ability to kind of like
interact like I like my older friends,
like we'll sit around,
we'll tell stories and it's like we'll
have fun.
And it's like the younger generation
when you watch them interact,
it's almost comical.
It's like these people like socially
awkward,
like they don't like people don't know
how to like approach girls anymore.
It's just like in the whole thing has
been reduced to like online dating,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a new world
for sure.
I mean,
I don't know there's a new world,
but what I found really fascinating is
that because I travel a lot doing stand
up is that there's no dumb places
anymore.
Like you can go to,
you know,
fill in the blank some place in the
middle of the Midwest,
Boise,
Idaho or whatever.
And you'll do a show there and the
fucking people are on the ball.
They know what the fuck's going on
there.
There's so much more informed.
When I used to travel on the road in the
nineties when I used to do stand up in
the nineties and you know,
fly into Ohio or sorry Jamie,
fly into someplace in the middle of the
country is fucking people were apes.
I mean they didn't know anything.
They were like,
what's it like to be on an airplane?
Mean fucking didn't know anything.
No one.
But now it's like you run into the same
kind of people in la that you can run
into in fill in the blank,
you know,
Phoenix or whatever,
wherever the fuck it is.
There's no dumb cities anymore because
you're still gonna.
Find some dumb people.
But I think overall the awareness level
of people has changed and I think that's
a lot due to the internet,
you know,
honest that accident.
I mean,
when I was a kid,
if I wanted to know something,
her mom's like,
okay,
look it up and the encyclopedia
Britannica.
And I'm like fuck that.
I'm not going to do that.
And we literally would have like
hundreds of encyclopedias around the
thing and like,
you know,
we thought that was great,
but now it's like you want to know
something,
you google it and you just instantly
know it.
Like you don't even have to press it,
you just talk into your phone.
You don't have to type,
you know?
Yeah.
You just ask Siri.
It's like google cold fusion shows you
instantaneously.
I mean,
it's so freaky that they didn't even
think about it in star trek or star
wars.
None of those places had the internet.
None of those visions of science fiction
in the future had the internet.
It's,
it's,
it's.
I think it's going to be when,
when history is all said and done,
when people look back on this era as
it's going to be one of the biggest
changes in the human race ever.
And we're in the middle of it.
It's a storm and we're just caught up in
it.
And like you were talking about when you
were saying how you're so wealthy and
it's just normal,
it just becomes normal to you to have
all this money and someone gives you a
Lamborghini.
It's normal.
Well,
this wealth of information is normal to
us.
It just seems normal,
you know,
and you know,
my kids are young,
they're grown up with the internet their
whole life.
They've never experienced anything but
the internet.
So it's to them they're not gonna know
how weird it was to run into bullshit
artists now.
People just lied about stuff.
Like you couldn't google them,
you know,
now you can just like,
if you want to know about somebody
fucking google them and it's like,
okay,
this guy's a scam artist.
This chick's a hooker.
You just got their life story.
It's like Bam,
like wikipedia or else.
Yeah,
it's Kinda crazy.
Before we did the podcast,
we started talking about psychedelics
and you started talking about some
psychedelic experiences that you had.
And I still like save it,
save it,
because I wanted to talk to you about it
on the air.
So tell me,
tell me what,
what has happened?
I mean,
you actually,
the one that turned me onto it,
the DMT.
Um,
I was,
the first time I tried,
I was at burning man and I smoked a
small amount of it.
Um,
and it was interesting.
I was,
I mean,
it was,
I felt like it was a pretty enlightening
experience.
Um,
I tried it a second time.
We had this small Malik,
how many hits?
Just one,
just one.
So I was uh,
you know,
it wasn't like deep in it or anything.
It's got to the doorway.
Took a look inside.
Yeah.
And I just,
I don't know,
it felt like a little bit of sense of
peace and clarity,
you know,
but that was all I really got from it.
The second time I did not have a good
experience.
I had this,
a Shaolin monk come over and he a priest
or whatever you call them and um,
I don't know if we did too much,
but I just didn't really get too much.
I actually got more out of it after,
um,
but during the experience it was like,
it was just too much.
I didn't really get anything.
It was just almost like overwhelming.
Yeah.
It was just overwhelming where like,
yeah,
it was almost like a,
almost like a video game,
kind of the best way to describe it
where I just like kinda almost seemed
like everything was kind of like
separating apart,
um,
but didn't really get too much.
Um,
and then the third time I had a similar
experience.
Um,
but that was,
that was just a smoking.
I haven't done Iowasca or anything like
that.
I did mushrooms three times.
Um,
it was funny.
I,
I had a couple,
so the first time I did mushrooms I
think goes was in high school and I just
never forget because it was like 1:30
in the morning or whatever.
And I just wanted to call all my friends
and tell them how great it was and have
conversation.
I remember them picking up the phone,
like Cheetahs 30 fuck off,
but I was just like,
I want to talk to everybody.
I was like,
I was having a good time and then I did
an Amsterdam,
got sick and it was funny because I
actually did it four times.
The third time I did it,
we were in Amsterdam and we were walking
down this long alleyway and we were
probably about 75 yards down the
alleyway and a buddy of mine,
it was like,
oh,
give me a second,
and we kept walking and we turn around
about five seconds later,
10 seconds later,
and he was gone and it was probably like
a 200 yard.
Allie,
where's,
I mean this guy was fucking Ben Johnson.
He couldn't have made.
It was like a long,
long alleyway there.
If he was in a dead sprint is a fast guy
in the world.
He couldn't have made it the end and
there was no like no ladders,
no nothing.
We're just like,
what the fuck happened and this dude,
we're just like,
and nobody can and we haven't even
really started tripping,
but we're like,
we thought this do got abducted by
aliens.
There was like no explanation,
right?
With like turnaround and we're just
like,
we all looked at each other like,
what the fuck happened?
And we knew these mushrooms are gonna
hit soon.
So we're just like,
but we didn't feel it.
We're like,
the mushrooms ain't hit.
We just ate it like,
you know,
five,
10,
whatever,
you know.
And it hadn't hit,
walked around the corner and there was a
police station were like,
Oh shit,
like I guess we should ask them.
And we went in there and we're like,
we don't know what happened or a
friendly,
we don't know if he got or whatever.
And we're like,
he looks like this.
And so there's this long alleyway,
right?
And this motherfucker chose the one spot
to piss where apparently there was like
a secret door that opened inward into
the police station and there was a
camera facing down and he was pissing on
the door.
The police station,
they grabbed a mid pissed stick still
out in the fucking police station and
throw them in jail.
And it's.
So we get this information,
we're like,
oh fuck,
like what do we gotta do?
Like we got to pay this guy,
like we're like,
this dude never done mushrooms before.
His first experience,
he's going to be in a jail in Amsterdam.
This guy's my gonna fucking lose his
mind.
Like we gotta get them out.
So we ended up paying these people and
then like,
I forget,
we've got to pay them a lot because I
was in college.
I remember it was like a significant
amount of money for us,
but we bailed them out.
And then I ended up.
I remember I offered like the chicken,
the counter.
I was like,
I'll give you 100 bucks if you'll mail
this to his parents or the video of
pissing and getting arrested if you met
his parents,
get the fuck out.
So that was number three.
And then the fourth time I did it,
I was in,
um,
it was that trip that I took to Puerto
Vallarta.
And uh,
when I took my buddy that one,
the or he got second in the world series
of poker and I,
and I'll never forget it because I was
um,
I was downstairs and we had this,
this,
this big villa on the edge of a cliff
and I remember not wanting to have sex
and I was just like,
this is the greatest thing for the first
time.
Like my Dick doesn't control me.
Like I like this is so,
you know,
this is so nice to just be able to like
relax and not like because we had all
these chicks running around.
I was like banging on the whole weekend
and I was like,
just not even like half to like think
about it because I have no desire to
have sex right now.
I remember having that thought and being
like,
wow,
this is great and I'm so fucked up that
I like took that as a personal challenge
to like see if I can have sex.
I'm fucking this girl for like 40
minutes on mushrooms on mushrooms.
It was the craziest bucket experience
ever.
I didn't even really enjoy it that much.
But I just remember at the end of it I
was like,
wow,
like you had this opportunity where like
you were not consumed with wanting to
have sex and he could put the fucking
ruined it foot.
Um,
I had a mushroom trip.
I was,
um,
I was with my friend Eddie and we were
near a mountain.
It was a very high hill.
We were below it and we were laying down
in the grass just laughing and giggling
and I don't know if you've ever,
like,
if you've ever been like lying down
looking up at a mountain range and you
see the sky and the clouds go overhead.
It was the first time,
I think in my life that I really took in
the concept of an atmosphere of this
shape of the earth being round and that
behind that atmosphere,
I'm to look it up as blue sky.
It's beautiful.
But I didn't see the blue sky anymore.
Saw it.
I knew it was there,
but I realized that it's just this
layer.
And then beyond that is the vast
infinity of space.
And I remember looking at it and
thinking for the first time because of
this hill I could see like,
oh,
like oh my God,
we're like in a convertible spaceship.
Like this whole thing is a space ship.
Like this is an illusion.
We're,
we're,
we're standing here like we're on
ground,
we're laying down on the grass looking
up at the sky,
but this is not,
this is not sky,
this is a thin layer of atmosphere
that's protecting you from space.
And then above that is there's no end to
it.
And it fucking stuck in my head.
That idea for the very first time.
And it's something about being below a
mountain and laying down and looking up
and seeing them out and seeing the air
and seeing the clouds go where it just
said into my mind like,
well that's an atmosphere.
This isn't just the sky,
this is a.
So I,
from that moment on,
I can look up at a mountain now and I'll
get this weird,
almost like half trippy feeling that.
That's one thing that I've heard
actually about a lot of psychedelics is
that it is not like,
it doesn't like rewire you,
but it just makes you think about
certain things differently and I think
that they,
they explained that there's some
chemical thing or kind of like almost
like resets you to like where you can
have a new perspective on certain
things.
That's one of the things that I read.
I was considering doing acid at burning
man this last year,
um,
because I've heard from a lot of people
that it's like,
it's more like clean form of the
mushrooms and they kinda like got more
out of it and I had like 10 people tell
me that it was like the best experience
or life.
And so that's like a pretty strong
statement of 10 people tell you that.
So yeah,
I did it this year for the first time.
It's a,
I wouldn't say it's like a,
it's,
it's powerful.
I mean they're all amazing.
They all have their own little thing
that goes on with them.
But the um,
the changing of perspective is really
beneficial to people that have
addictions.
Like apparently people that smoke
cigarettes,
like they'll have a powerful mushroom
trip and they don't have any desire to
smoke cigarettes anymore.
It's a really common experience.
Drug addicts and you know,
even people that probably have other
weird addictions like gambling
addictions or sex addictions like,
yeah.
Like I said,
I think I had a small experience like
that with the sex thing on the mushrooms
and it was pretty liberating.
Yeah.
I mean I think for a lot of people they
get trapped in the momentum of the life
that they're in,
whatever it is.
And sometimes psychedelic trips or you
know,
sometimes for people it's just a near
death experience.
You almost drowned.
You don't drown.
You get out of there and you're like,
Holy Shit,
I got to rethink my whole life.
And he just just changes who you are.
Like the reset.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
and I've preached this for a long time.
I think just so much of your life is
just perspective.
I mean,
it really is.
And I,
I,
you know,
a lot of times I have these,
um,
these crazy part is on
white disabled veterans out or whatever
and try and show them a good time.
And it's one time I,
uh,
had this one guy who got both his legs
blown off in Afghanistan and super cool
dude,
like really humble,
nice guy.
And um,
there's this like super hot chick that
was at the,
at the party and I really wanted to fuck
her,
but I was like,
ah,
see if she can get her to fuck him.
And uh,
I,
I paid her a fucking ton of money,
which is kind of fucked,
fuck this guy.
And uh,
and I,
I was,
I was fucked up and I ended up passing
out and I forgot about it.
And the next day we're sitting there at
breakfast and um,
I was just like,
I'm so fucking miserable.
And I look over at this dude and almost
like,
you know,
what the fuck are you so happy.
He's like,
smiling and eat this shit and you know,
I'm hung over.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you so happy about?
You know,
he's like,
shit man.
He's like,
I feel great.
Oh,
you're not hung over.
He's like,
yeah.
I don't give a shit though.
And uh,
and I'm just like,
dude,
I got to ask you man.
I'm like,
he got you got the fucking best
attitude.
I was like,
since you've been here has always been
fucking positive.
I was like,
you know,
is it ever like,
do you ever have moments where you're
just like fucking depressed about,
you know,
the,
the fucking amputation or any of that
stuff was exact fuck with you.
I was like,
how do you like,
how do you maintain such a good attitude
as I think it's amazing.
And he's like,
what are you talking about?
I was like,
losing my legs.
The best thing that ever happened to me
and I'll just never forget it because
that statement was just like,
so,
like different from what I ever expected
this guy to say.
Right.
And he followed it up with,
you know,
if that never happened to me,
he's like,
I'd be over in fucking some sand pit and
Afghanistan,
I'd just be another number and nobody
gives a shit about me.
He goes,
and then when I came home he's like,
I just be,
you know,
fucking military guy and everybody in my
town wouldn't care.
And he's like,
now he's like,
I go and I motivate people and I give
these speeches.
He goes and people look up to me and I'm
inspiring people.
He's like,
and I get to do cool shit.
I just got a fucking brand new rifle the
other week for free.
He goes to military is paying me.
He goes,
I'm fucking party in here with you
fucked a super hot chick class.
I know that.
I remembered.
I was like,
oh good.
And then it was just like funny though
because like his whole thought process
about it was so great and I could just
see how another guy,
if that happened to them,
could easily like get into like the woe
is me and the whole like,
you know,
fuck this,
depressed and,
you know,
think about all the time,
like how could this have gone,
you know,
but this guy just like accepted it,
fucking charge with it.
And I was just like,
he viewed it as like a huge positive.
And I thought that was great.
I don't know if you've ever seen,
um,
I got this youtube thing.
It's like the story of the Chinese
farmer.
You ever seen that?
No,
we're.
So he loses his horse and everybody in
the town comes over and they say,
oh,
well that's,
that's terrible.
And he's like,
I'm.
And they're like,
oh,
well that's terrible now,
isn't it?
And he's like,
maybe.
And then the next day seven wild horses
come back and they all come over and
they say,
oh,
well that's great.
And he says,
well,
maybe the next day his kid is taken out,
one of the wild horses and breaks his
leg and the whole town comes over and
they say,
oh,
that's terrible.
Now in it.
He says,
maybe the next day the conscription
officers come over and they're,
you know,
taking people into the military to go
fight and they pass by his son because
he's got a broken leg and the whole town
comes over and they say,
you know,
and they say,
oh,
that's great now.
And then he says,
maybe.
And the point of it is that you never
really know if something is bad or good
because you don't know how that's gonna
affect the rest of your life.
Like back,
you know,
when I fuck up two days before graduated
seal training,
I've done 510 days of it.
I'll put my fucking heart and soul into
this fucking thing and I get kicked out
because some fucking guy doesn't like
me.
And you know,
it's kind kinda hard to look at that in
any way other than,
oh,
that's fucking terrible.
But as I'm older and I've experienced a
lot,
I can look at that and be like,
well,
half of my class died right in combat so
I could have fucking died.
Um,
if I would have became a navy seal,
then that might've just been like what I
hung my hat on,
you know,
and I was just like,
for the rest of my life I didn't feel
like I really needed to fucking prove
anything or excel or do anything because
I've done this thing that everybody uses
great.
And you know,
I don't know if I would've been as
motivated.
And so there's just a lot of things like
that and your life that in the short
term you look at them as being extreme
negatives or you know,
something that you view as positive
that,
you know,
it's just hard to say until,
it's Kinda like run its course and you
see what effects that has later on down
the line.
We're going to end it with some deep
shit.
Dan Bilzerian,
I knew I'd get some deep shit out of
you.
I knew it was in there.
God Damn it.
Thank you very much,
man.
I really appreciate it.
It was a lot of fun.
Really appreciate it.
Uh,
obviously instagram.
Then twitter,
the same.
Right?
Thanks brother.
That was fun.
Good Times night everybody.
Oh,
we'll be back tomorrow with Jesse
Ventura.
Holy Shit.
Cool.